Five four,
three,
two,
one.
Legit.
Hello Bill.
Hey Man.
What's going on here?
You are here with a book.
You got a book of Shit.
I got to come prepared.
I mean,
yeah,
I'm trying to write,
I'm trying to get back into handwriting.
Uh,
for people don't know.
Bill is the CEO and cofounder of mines.com and we've been going back and forth
through email and you got hoax by some dude who said he was Joey Diaz.
It did happen.
He really believed you.
Like Joey's been on my network and I'm like,
he was messaging me,
messaging me in Joey's voice.
Like basically cloning it.
Like there's weird people out there,
man.
Yeah.
Well that's not hard to do.
You know?
Yeah.
And watched enough Joey just cloning his,
his tweets.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Every Monday morning or so there's a,
there's a tweet about someone needs to suck your Dick.
That's it.
They need to suck your Dick.
You need a lot of no,
that's uh,
on the regular.
Um,
what's the notes man?
Just some ramblings from this morning.
Yeah.
Important stuff.
It's actually the first thing that I,
uh,
I've written in this notebook.
I've not been doing handwriting lunch at all in the last years,
probably mostly digital,
which is not good because I actually majored in English.
So yeah,
you definitely lose your ability to write words.
It's funny,
I tried riding in,
um,
uh,
for whatever reason I wrote mostly in all caps,
you know,
cause I just mostly just write notes.
But I tried writing with like lowercase letters and then I tried writing in
cursive and my cursive is like,
it's almost like I have to relearn it.
Yeah.
I was finding and just like trailing off at the end of certain words.
But I blended all together.
He what?
I blended all together with capital and lower case o.
Why you do that?
I mean,
well just as a normal person would proper grammar.
I thought you were just mixing them up randomly.
No,
no.
Okay.
No,
I did write my,
uh,
college thesis in all lower case y hyped.
I don't read protesting.
Yeah,
kind of.
It was stupid.
It's like a cool move.
Right?
I'm not going to use any upper case.
Who Cares,
man.
There's weird like postmodern theory about like capitalization and that's kind
of what I was talking about.
I got a little bit and doctrinated at Ed Uvm to be really?
Yeah.
They're like,
they,
this one class,
it was called credit.
Which one is you?
What does Uvm,
Vermont.
Vermont,
yeah.
Oh,
Vermont is like,
yeah.
Super Social.
Justicey right.
And paved with good intentions.
Yeah.
So great ice cream up there to [inaudible] nice folks.
But like this one class was called critical theory and we had to watch Buffy the
vampire slayer and apply like Marxist theory to it to show how like it's the
rise up of the lower class.
It's like you're forced to write these papers in like a certain way.
Yeah.
What were they trying to prove?
Class,
division.
Class.
Division.
Yeah.
In Buffy the vampire slayer.
It's there.
There's like books and books written about Buffy the vampire slayer and Marxism.
Yeah.
Come on.
Not Kidding.
Railing.
Yep.
What do they have to say?
I don't remember to go into it.
It's amazing.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm sure you're aware of a James Lindsey and Peter Boghossian and what does it
so Glen's name?
Yes.
Helen Shit,
I didn't meet her unfortunately.
Um,
the grievance studies hoaxes that they submitted a bunch of a fake studies to
these journals and not only got reviewed but got lauded and praised for their
academic scholarship.
Yeah.
That I think that standing from this Guy Sokol who first trolled a lot of the
postmodern journals and he was the first,
and so it's called a socal hoax to do that kind of trolling.
It's hard to figure out who's who.
Right.
It's hard to figure out what's the hoax.
I got a trick by that.
There's this one thing called the postmodernism generator online.
It's a computer that writes articles that puts all of this fancy language
together and I,
someone sent it to me and I showed it to my teacher and I was like,
oh,
this is,
this is saying something pretty interesting.
But it was,
it was horse shit.
Yeah.
What do you a,
you know,
what do you make of all this?
Hoaxing you've been hoaxed twice then you just admitted in the first admitted to
the show.
I mean,
I think that you sort of have to have the right to,
to hoax a hoax to be wrong,
to mess up.
Well,
that's not messing up.
That's deceiving people.
True.
Um,
but you kind of have the right to do that too.
You kind of have the right to troll.
Yeah.
You don't have the right to impersonate,
but I have the right to get trolled and be wrong.
Well,
you don't have the right to impersonate.
Like you can't have a verified account.
Pretend you'd Joey Diaz.
Oh no,
of course not.
But harmless trolling like that guy did to you.
Isn't that kind of like part of freedom?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just comes down this info from social networks because it's wrong.
That doesn't make sense.
It,
it,
it also depends on,
does that make sense?
I mean
like if someone is purposely,
okay,
let's say that you find some Chinese bought that's purposely disseminating
incorrect and negative information about maybe a potential presidential
candidate.
Let's pick one Tulsi Gabbert there are disseminating fake news about her.
And you know for sure that it's fake,
you know for sure who the,
I don't know how you know,
but you know for sure who the source of it is.
You don't think that should be taken down?
I think that if it's illegal it should be taken down.
If it's illegal.
Yeah.
Okay.
But it was just lies then.
That could be illegal.
I'm not a lawyer so I,
I'm trying to position the network or just like advocate for other networks to
take more of a neutral stance.
There's this cool thing called the Manila principles,
which the Electronic Frontier Foundation wrote with a bunch of other Internet
freedom groups,
which is talking about how digital and intermediaries should,
shouldn't be making subjective decisions about what's getting taken down and
should require a court order now with a DNS provider or you know,
something less content focused,
playing DNS to people don't know.
We don't like a domain name.
So explain what that is.
It's like where you buy domain and you know,
but for a soldier now or we're hosting tons of content,
so it's harder for us because we see illegal content in it.
We should proactively take some of it down if we know it's illegal,
but at the same time,
you know it's just slippery.
Well,
I follow quite a few people who have a,
I want to,
I don't want to say they have hoax accounts,
but they have parody accounts and they,
and you know a lot of people read into it wrong and think they're being honest
and argue with them like a,
there's a,
there's progressive dad guy on Instagram your fall,
him know exactly what you're talking about.
This hilarious when I fall it too.
That's pretty funny.
I follow quite a few of them.
There was a guy who was the wrong skin guy who was saying he was born in the
wrong color skin,
that he's trans racial and he would make these ridiculous arguments about it and
Elwick.
What was his name?
He apparently is a comic.
I was just thinking of this,
this sort of star,
a couple,
I don't know the moment they had to do it,
but let's say four years ago a lot of those troll accounts had to sort of say,
we're not this person.
For instance,
the one main one I follow is a,
is now,
now it's known as not Bill Walton.
He tweets funny sports jokes all night long after like what's on TV as though
he's Bill Walton,
Mike and Bill Walton.
But like at some point he had to put in the name like this is not bill Walton,
but still has quite a few followers and he's still,
he still gets the jokes out,
but
that's from,
yeah.
Well what's your stance on people who make accounts of your stuff?
Put it out there?
Well,
I got with a lot of them,
you know,
um,
there's a ton of them.
Some of them actually do good stuff.
Like they make little clips and they put those clips online and it's actually,
it's good.
It's good for people enjoy the show.
They get a little one minute snippet of things and then some of them just will
pretend to be me and contact people and try to book them on the show,
which is really weird.
Oh yeah,
I've had that.
Um,
but you know,
I mean,
who is that?
Is that a 16 year old kid in Indiana?
I mean,
who is that?
It's uh,
it's odd.
It's,
but it's overall like get past my own personal feelings.
Uh,
because,
uh,
because it's about me,
it's interesting.
This is the,
you know,
this,
this strange new ground that we're covering.
You know,
mean we've been discussing this ad nauseum on the podcast lately that
essentially we've been dealing with 20 years of this and in those 20 years it's
changed radically.
I mean,
what it is,
it's become something completely different.
It's become something that changes public opinion on things overnight.
It's
become something where you can distribute information from,
you know,
person to person about some,
huge international news event.
You could get all of your information from Twitter,
whether it's what happened in Venezuela or what,
you know,
anywhere there's something in the world.
You,
your people are turning to social media almost before they're turn anywhere
you're looking.
I,
you know,
when I hear about something,
I almost always,
before I even Google it,
I almost always go to Twitter and check Twitter and you know,
and see what's going on.
And she had us that go at duck duck,
go.
Have you heard of that one?
No,
it's at,
it's like a privacy focused search engine.
It's like pretty much the only privacy alternative to Google.
It's like this idea that we say,
I'll just Google it.
Right.
Why do we,
I mean our whole process has been to like purge proprietary surveillance tools
from our company and I've been trying to get myself like getting off Facebook,
getting off Twitter,
getting off Instagram.
It's just like there's so abusive to everybody and it's like there's brilliant
people who work there.
I mean Instagram is such a well designed app or you can beautiful,
but so what do you think is abusive about it particularly?
There's start with Twitter.
They're all the same.
Yeah.
Do you think they're all the same?
Because they're all gigantic businesses.
Yeah.
And they're all the same because none of them share their source code and they
all spy on everybody and they don't show you what is happening behind the
scenes.
They don't show you what the code is doing.
So like in that,
in that note I wrote to the other day,
it's like I compare it to like food transparency.
You know,
50 years ago nobody thought about that.
And then 20 years ago everyone's like,
I want to know what's in my food white.
But why wouldn't you want to know what's in your apps?
Yeah,
I mean it's super sketchy what they're doing,
but how so like what,
what supers can,
I don't know.
But we know that they're spying on everyone and tracking you everywhere you go.
They're targeting things at you based on physical location,
browser history,
even when you're not on those websites,
some of their falling around where you're going in the Internet.
Right.
And so some people except that for this free search engine would free email and
things along those lines.
The PSAP except the fact that a certain percentage of what they're doing is not
going to be private,
or at least their searches are not going to be probably like say if you circle
you thinking about buying a jeep and you searched jeeps,
you look at,
you know,
2019 jeep and then all of a sudden all your Google ads are about jeeps,
right?
They'll like,
we know,
we know you thinking about the jeep bill and I don't think that that makes
people want to spend more time on Google and Facebook.
If fruity he does.
Do you think it freaks them out?
I think that we're just numb to it and so we accept it,
but I think it's more that.
Yeah.
And so there's all different layers of like what we use
with your browsers,
your apps,
your operating system,
your food,
your,
you know,
government,
your energy.
Like all of this technology has code that's associated with it.
So,
and when you open up your computer,
when you sign into a browser,
when you open up an app,
you are empowering that APP.
That's how the apps of the world become huge,
monstrous corporations.
This because we all use them every day.
Right?
So if you switch from,
you know,
oh at Macko s to like a new Lenox or like Debbie and urban too,
if you use brave or Firefox,
if you um,
you know,
Duckduckgo is actually proprietary,
which is annoying,
but they are very privacy focused.
And then there's apps,
there's minds,
there's all sorts of,
there's other open source of decentralized social networks out there that we can
potentially federate with.
There's really cool new interesting protocols like dat and IPFS that are like
more torn style backend.
So there's actually no servers in a giant warehouse like Facebook and Google.
It's more,
it's fully peer to peer and we're trying to balance it because it's not like
decentralization equals good and centralization equals bad.
But like,
you know,
in order to get a suite app like Instagram style,
you need servers to like process video.
And so the tech is still sort of immature in the fully peer to peer,
like,
you know,
bitcoin style internet.
But we're definitely getting there.
And I just think it's important for people to use things that are transparent to
them and respecting our freedom.
Yeah.
I think one of the problems with these giant companies is that once they become
big,
he kind of used them as a default.
And it's very difficult to get people to communicate with you off of them.
You know?
It's,
it's a hard to say,
hey man,
I'm,
I'm launching this new social media APP.
I would imagine you could speak to this.
I'm launching this new social media APP and,
uh,
I want you to join it.
People like put them already on fucking Facebook.
I'm already on Google.
I'm Ernie on Instagram.
I don't want to do that,
man.
It's too much,
too much extra.
And we make it a million times harder for ourselves because we're not scooping
it
people's contacts and,
you know,
taking all their information.
You are not,
we're minds.
No.
Okay.
So like when you give your address book to a App,
who does that?
Every most apps would be,
you've gotta be an Asshole,
you know?
But no,
but when you say,
oh,
I want to find my friends who are on this app and you share your contacts,
we not supposed to do that.
You're not supposed to do that.
Yeah.
But most people do.
And you know,
your friends didn't give you permission to give Facebook their phone number.
Do you do that?
I probably used to like
seven,
eight years ago,
whatever.
But don't do it anymore.
I always say the same thing when it pops up kit though.
Fuck Outta here.
That's always what I say.
Would you like to share your,
your contacts?
Get the fuck Outta here.
No,
you can't have my contacts.
You asshole.
I know what you're doing.
Facebook is weird one man.
It's so,
it's such a sneaky
one.
You know,
Facebook and it,
you know,
like all this,
uh,
the,
the congressional hearings and the inner workings of it all.
And w there the fact that it profits off of outrage.
So it wants people to argue like the,
the Ai,
the computer learning specifically wants people to have like contentious debates
about things.
Cause that keeps their eyes focused on the website.
And if your eyes are focused on Facebook,
you know,
then those Facebook ads are very valuable.
It's really fascinating,
man.
I think the outrage is unavoidable on any network.
It's more,
you know,
are you gonna are you going to take down there taking down outrage,
Tom?
Yeah,
sure.
So,
and it just seems so inconsistent and subjective how they're applying.
I mean,
even just yesterday,
I think some,
uh,
journalists got banned from Facebook.
Yeah.
Let me,
I'm going to send this to you Jamie.
Cause it's,
it's a really crazy one because they wanted her to show who her funding sources
were and I didn't even know that there was an area where you could show that.
So it's almost like they're making this up as they go along.
Yeah.
Kyle Kalinsky sent me this today.
I'm going to send this to you right now.
Jamie.
Hang on one second.
Oh,
hold on.
I'm a very quiet,
unfortunately this is an audio show,
but it's alive there.
Yes.
Not Dead Air.
There you go.
Okay,
buddy.
I just sent it to you.
Okay.
Uh,
Facebook suspended in the now tweets,
uh,
page at the behest of CNN and the u s government funded think tanks.
Says we had almost 4 million subscribers,
did not violate Facebook rules were given no warning and Facebook isn't
responding to us.
So yeah.
What is,
what was the,
what it would actually started this off?
I mean,
who knows?
They don't communicate with anyone.
They've been banning legit accounts for years.
They,
you cannot even send a mines.com the link through Facebook messenger right now.
It's blocked.
What?
Yeah,
whites,
if you post in the newsfeed,
it says,
careful,
this could be an unsecure website.
Oh,
just I clicked on a link from TMZ yesterday and got the same thing from on
Twitter.
I said this might be malicious.
They're spam.
There could be from minds.
No,
it's from Tia.
TMZ Link.
It was clicking this like this story is on TMZ here to us.
You the,
the rest of the story.
So they're trying to keep you from going to TMZ.
Yeah.
I don't know why it was the first time I've ever seen that.
Huh.
It's probably caught up in some algorithm and I sent an actual written letter to
Facebook about it.
Obviously I don't get back.
And then there's no human written letter.
He wrote it with a piece of paper known now that would have been cool.
I sign it with ink,
but really we had no cars.
Our lawyer said to you,
that actually proves that you sent them something,
some sort of diligence,
but there's just no recourse and it's their lost.
So explain.
So if someone is trying to say on Facebook master,
Hey,
you should go check out minds.com they won't let you post that link now.
And what is their excuse?
They don't tell you.
You know,
they don't tell you.
So is it because you're competing social media network?
I don't know.
I don't want to get into,
You don't know?
I'm not going to say,
just know that it does.
Yeah.
You don't know why it does,
but you know,
it doesn't,
they're calling us unsecure and I'm pretty sure that Facebook got hacked.
You know,
they compromise everybody's data.
Like,
do you want to talk about unsecure?
There's no more unsecure site that exists.
It is kind of funny,
right?
I mean after those hearings and uh,
after all the,
uh,
the Russia stuff,
yeah.
It's um,
it is kind of funny calling somebody else on secure.
Yeah,
they're insecure.
Mark Zuckerberg was very insecure.
Well,
he's also stupid rich.
He,
um,
he seems like he's too rich.
Like he fucked up.
Like he's there sipping water,
like a robot trying to figure out what the fuck he's doing with his life.
I think that they're scared because they know they've betrayed everybody and so
it's hard to get them to speak.
You know,
it was interesting with,
with Dorsey here because I,
you know,
give him credit for speaking,
but the fact is that he's not answering the question well,
he's bringing someone else in to answer the questions in the next go round.
And so that should be very interesting.
He actually didn't know the answer to those questions.
I think he probably doesn't know all the specifics because he's a CEO of not
one,
but two different corporations,
these busy shit and also Richard,
but true.
But I think that when we look at the policy that exists on these networks,
like he is in control of the policy to large degree,
there's a board decision,
there's a decision making process,
but he has a large voice.
Okay.
I don't know how large his voices,
I assume that's probably true,
but one of the things we did detail on the last podcast with Tim Pool was how he
wasn't the CEO for quite a long time fired and then rehired it.
Yeah.
So,
um,
obviously there's some contention,
there's some issues and you know,
there's a,
it's a lot of money involved in these things and I think that plays a giant part
and how they decide to make decisions and,
but do you think that an advertiser in reality doesn't like,
say you're an advertiser and you want to advertise your computer.
Okay.
And there's a video on youtube that is about something controversial.
Does it actually make sense for that advertiser to not show their product on
that controversial video?
Don't they want to sell computers?
Uh,
well it depends.
I mean,
if the controversial videos are about how Jews are evil and you have this video
about Jews being evil and then you know,
you're like by razor computers come on.
Right?
But do you think that people actually,
I can understand not wanting to support certain types of content and maybe
advertisers feel like they're supporting that content by advertising next to it.
But I also don't think that people,
when they're watching a controversial video on the Internet say,
oh my gosh,
you know,
this advertiser is completely out of line for being next to this controversial
thing.
I,
I don't think that's a,
a healthy direction to move.
Well,
okay,
that's one way to look at it.
Another way to look at it is if you are a giant company that sells things,
let's say you're Toyota and you're selling Tundras,
you don't want your Tundras to be associated in any way with something that you
might think is negative.
It's their prerogative.
If they're paying for advertising,
they can kind of decide.
This is one of the things that's leading,
um,
youtube and specific,
and I've had
a ton of conversations about this there.
It's leading them specifically to try to monetize things that could be
considered distasteful or insensitive or controversial.
And it's very frustrating to content creators when you talk to them.
They're essentially saying that they need to do better and that their tools are
very blunt,
that they don't really have the correct computer learning tools to figure out
what is offensive and why.
And then there's a human review system,
which is very weird and we've run into that many times.
We're like,
we'll have like a podcast with like say Tom Papa who's an uncontroversial
fantastic standup comedian and it's like demonetized and then we're like,
why?
What happened?
And then we go,
what the fuck can we talk about?
We didn't talk about anything crazy.
And it's really damaging for brands when it gets the monetize right away.
Cause it's that initial time period that generates the most revenue.
Yeah.
So when you have to go back and do it,
I mean,
so I agree with that,
but so we built a tool that's like a peer to peer advertising tool.
So it's not,
there's two options.
You can say you earn crypto for your contributions and then which Cryptos do you
support?
We have an ethereum based token,
but we're going to support all of them.
So what is a theory on base token?
So it's an Erc 20 token.
What does that mean?
It means that we basically reward people for all of their activities.
Okay,
so let's say if Jamie's posted on mines and uh,
people love his posts,
he gets rewarded in some,
yeah.
How much?
How much again?
Well,
can I go buy one token will give you a thousand impressions.
Oh,
so you were not focused on like,
oh,
you're going to make money from this one.
We're saying one token will give you a thousand impressions or you get a
thousand impressions from,
you get a token from 1000 impressions want when you use a token to advertise on
mine.
Oh,
you get a thousand impressions when you boost your posts with it.
So wait a minute.
If you use the Crypto,
you use a token.
You guarantee views.
Yeah.
Well that's word,
isn't it?
Why?
Well,
you're guaranteeing people see something.
we,
when you boosted it gets fed to people's newsfeed chronologically,
right?
I say so there's just a backlog.
So sort of like when Instagram has a sponsored posts,
except we're not spying on people to,
when we send them Instagram Spaz on people to mine.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I'm stupid.
Help me out.
It's,
yes they do.
And the thing is we just don't know.
So this is where free and open source software is just essential.
Like the big networks,
there's no excuse for them not to be sharing their software.
Right.
It's like when you're a public forum on that scale,
the community just has a right to know what the algorithms are doing.
So you think that they're not sharing their software because their software is
encoded and designed to spy on you and extract information and sell that
information?
Partially like when Jamie gives up your contacts,
when he signs up for an APP and he says,
yes,
you can get access to all my contacts.
There's a lot of reason and they don't want people to compete with them.
Like anyone could actually take all of our code and make their own social
network and compete with us.
They could set up on their own servers and we encourage that.
That's what like the Fed averse is called.
That's what Elon Musk does with Tesla.
All of his electric patents for electric cars.
I think that he opened up the pants.
I don't think if he,
he opened sourced all the,
the code of the car.
Right.
He's definitely in moving in the right direction of like he wants to build the
market.
Yes.
And he also wants to save the world.
I mean he legitimately has any also house shit,
load of money and just got enough money.
Yeah,
that's,
I think that's a big factor with those guys.
But don't,
don't you think that it's almost like it's going to help whatever network does
that Oh is more transparent,
stop spying on people.
Is More community run and evolved.
Wouldn't that be the network that you would think humanity would want to stick
with in the long term?
Like wouldn't that be a good move of them?
Yes and no.
For the average person.
What are they losing when they get on Facebook or Google?
What are the what?
What's bad?
What happens now their legs are going down,
everybody's likes are going down and that makes everyone very sad.
What do you mean?
Well,
the algorithms,
you're only reaching 5% of your own followers organically on Facebook now,
and they're starting to change the chronological feed on Instagram too.
And they know that this causes depression and they're still doing it because
they know that the,
you know,
they're,
they think they're better at showing you what you want to see than you are and
they want to make money from it.
What do you mean by they know that this causes depression?
They've done studies about mental health in relation to,
actually Facebook got exposed like five years ago for doing a secret study on
like a few million users where they were injecting both positive and negative
content into the newsfeed and they proved that they could affect people's moods.
This was with Princeton and there's a huge backlash and they're like,
oh,
sorry.
Whoops.
Right.
But this isn't of injecting negative or positive content.
This is just moving these images or these posts around so that less people
[inaudible] there's two different topics there.
The basic news feed on Facebook is now a mysterious conglomeration of thousands
of variables,
which we don't know.
And,
but additionally,
like a few years ago,
they were exposed for having been experimenting with people's brains.
That's right.
I remember that now.
I remember that now that that's right.
Yeah.
I remember thinking like,
wow,
that's kinda creepy.
[inaudible] on the people that are on their site and they're not telling these
people that are experimenting on them.
Yeah.
But do they,
I mean,
if they're trying to make it better,
um,
do you think that they're really,
that's a factor that it acts,
it actually mean how does it cause depression if they're just,
if your images or your posts are not being seen as by as many people
have you talked to kids posting on social media and their reactions to how many
likes they're getting,
they get very,
very,
um,
concerned.
Well,
that seems like more of a problem with that.
It is both.
It's not,
it is on both sides being addicted to likes as some sort of,
uh,
you know,
to weird dope.
Yeah.
Right.
It's not healthy and no,
we need to learn to not care about that.
But I think that the core purpose of a social network is to subscribe to someone
and see their stuff.
Yeah.
And when people subscribe to you,
they see your stuff,
right?
So when you spend years building up a following on social media and say you earn
100,000 followers or something,
and then suddenly the network says,
mm,
Nah,
now your friends can't see that anymore.
That's not cool.
And,
and even to like Twitter's default newsfeed is no longer chronological.
You have to click it to go chronological and then it defaults back to their
weird algorithm thing.
So we're saying,
look,
a hundred percent organic,
chronological,
raw forever as default.
And then if you want to curate,
you know,
algorithms or have recommended stuff come in as a alternative,
fine.
But that is the core purpose of social media is to connect with people that
follow you and the other way around.
Do you think the purposes,
like why do you think Facebook would decide to have things not in chronological
order and only be seen by 5% of your followers?
Like what will it be the benefit in that for them?
Revenue.
How so?
How's that generate revenue?
They just know that they can keep you on the app better if you had less likes.
No.
If your your stuff seen by less people,
it doesn't make sense.
That's a good point.
It sort of works both ways.
I think that they think they know the people that you're going to react to the
most.
So as a consumer,
when you're getting that content,
you know the algorithms are showing you what you typically like.
Have you noticed that?
I'm really not paying much attention but I don't believe you.
So yeah,
for Creator it's hurting creators.
People who post are getting hurt.
People who are sitting there just scrolling.
They're the ones who are really getting addicted more so with the algorithms.
So how are the people that are posting getting hurt?
They're getting hurt because their stuff is being seen by last people.
Yeah.
Because it's not chronological and it's an organic cause it's curated.
Huh.
But aren't they doing it because they think it's going to be a better and a,
an experience that's more conducive to your life?
That's what they say.
What do you think?
They're doing?
A four then they're doing it because they have studied through looking at the
data,
how to keep people on the APP more.
Right.
And that way is to give them like say if I Google or if I look at muscle cars on
Instagram now,
if I go to my search,
it's all muscle car stuff.
So that's what it is.
They say,
oh,
he likes that.
So we're going to,
we're just going to give him a lot of that.
And I think that's okay as an alternative feed or to put that somewhere.
I just think the core feed always needs to stay pure.
Hmm.
Because otherwise you're just down the slippery slope again and understand it's
just feeding their,
they're injecting things into your head that you didn't ask for.
Right.
And they're doing it because they want to keep you around.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Um,
how many different companies are subscribing to that is,
it seems like all the big ones were saying are curating and moving things around
and all the big ones have an algorithm that's designed to keep you on board.
Right.
And that's okay to pursue.
I think there's really cool things you can do with AI and machine learning and
algorithms that is really beneficial,
but it's just taking away people's reach when they have worked years and years
to achieve it.
It's not okay.
Do you think that this is this marriage between something that is this social
media network that's designed to allow people to communicate with each other and
then commerce like this business,
like how do we maximize this business?
How do we get more profit out of this business?
How do we get these people to engage more?
And then they start monkeying with the code and screw in with what you see and
what you don't say.
You think that's what's happening?
Yeah.
But in,
in the short term it's probably working,
but in the long term they're betraying everybody's trust.
It has to be more of a consent based system.
So you know,
at least give people,
well it should be a opt out by default and find,
give me messages to opt in so that you can show me certain things.
But this whole force forcing
people into surveillance has,
it just has to stop.
It's,
it's super scary.
How's the super scared of you?
It's just too much power.
Yeah,
it's too much power for something that supposed to be silly,
right?
Like what was Facebook supposed to supposed to be some silly thing that you just
can communicate with friends.
It was,
but from the beginning,
all of these,
none of these networks have ever really been about the people of the networks.
It's always been closed source since the inception.
So,
but then you look at open networks out there,
you have Wikipedia,
totally open source community.
Ryan granted they have their issues with moderation.
Fine.
But it's a top 10 website in the world is totally open source,
creative Commons content,
incredible human achievement,
bitcoin,
open source money.
Wordpress even is an open source CMS system that is like powering 25% of the
Internet.
So why when that happened with social media it should,
I mean this way everyone's hanging out so we should all sort of collectively
even own it.
We did a an equity crowdfunding round,
so like thousands members of our community actually on the site now.
How many people are on mines?
We have like a million and a half registered,
like quarter million active.
Various we're,
we're,
we're small.
But the weird thing is that even though we're a fraction of the size,
especially smaller creators who come get better reach on minds than they do on
Facebook and Twitter because we have this reward and incentive system sort of
like gamified where you earn breach and you earn more of a voice for
contributing.
So like you could have a account on Twitter for 10 years in post thousands and
thousands of tweets and you never hit that viral nerve and you just never,
never really get much exposure.
So we're trying to help people be heard.
And so you'll find a small creator who on other networks has no followers,
have thousands and thousands of followers on mines.
And what do you think you would like to do with mines in the future that you
haven't been able to do yet?
Engineer the control out of ourselves so that we aren't even in a position to
really,
you know,
take people's stuff down or who would have someone in posts your house and your
information where your kids go to school.
I think that on the central servers obviously yes,
we're always going to moderate and if it's legal it can stay.
If it's not illegal it can't.
But
a decentralized social network is definitely where we have to go because,
and yeah.
Okay.
It's,
it's scary.
And you know,
you've talked about this,
like things are getting more transparent.
Our lives is sort of like the inevitable evolution of technology.
I mean,
how many hours a day do you stream a couple,
you know,
25 years ago would you have thought you'd be sharing,
20% of your life live streaming to,
you know,
millions of people like you're,
our lives are becoming more transparent.
Just inevitably it's just pulling us.
Yeah,
I agree.
So,
you know,
bitcoin crypto,
dat torn Stipe,
torn type architecture.
That is just where we're going because it's more resilient,
it's less censorship prone,
there's just benefits of it.
I think that we can bounce it to like maybe when you post,
you have a,
a decision.
Do you want to be able to delete this at any point?
All right,
fine.
Then you can post the central server.
Do you want this to get unleashed?
Yeah.
It's scary because you know,
they're scary stuff on the Internet.
It's already like that.
But you know,
getting into censorship more.
But does censorship even solve the problem or does it make it worse?
What problem?
The problem of crazy content,
illegal content does it,
how could it make it worse?
Well,
I mean it seems like it can often amplify radicalization
definitely count,
right?
Yeah.
And it definitely,
um,
when you censor people,
it just makes them aware that there's plot against them too.
Right?
It's a lot of conservatives on Twitter are finding that.
Some of the,
Sam Harris actually just sent me an article.
Um,
it was a detailing the bias against conservatives on Twitter that they've
actually done,
you know,
like some real studying it and it's pretty demonstrated [inaudible] demonstrably
it affects both the left and the right wheel.
Too much trouble.
Yeah.
The way I'm saying it wrong.
Um,
but it's,
it affects the left and the right for sure.
Yeah,
that's what Kyle was saying.
I watched that video that he did and he said it's antiestablishment that seems
to be getting targeted.
And so,
you know,
Abby's been censored on face and I'd be willing to learn.
Um,
and yeah,
this person today,
I mean most of the stuff coming out of our t is progressive,
which is weird.
And who knows what kind of games are getting played behind the scenes with the
rush.
I mean,
who knows?
But the point is they have a right to be there.
And I mean,
look at,
this is not youtubes fault,
but remember the youtube shooter,
I mean,
she thought she was getting censored on Youtube and she went and brought a gun
to the youtube headquarters.
Like people get pissed when they get censored.
It affects you.
Right.
But in her case,
you're talking about a crazy person and loads of really being sensitive to
people out there.
Yeah.
No,
shoot.
Shashi wasn't being,
she was getting censored just like everybody else is getting soft censored on
these networks.
Well,
she just thought does,
it wasn't,
she didn't,
wasn't getting promoted the way she wanted to wait.
I don't think anybody was actively doing anything to her.
I'm not saying that her stuff was 10 saying that the soft censorship of the
algorithms,
people getting demonetized this has an impact on psychology.
Okay.
I see what you're saying.
So it's,
I'm saying they were deliberately targeting her and so horrible what happened,
but
yeah.
Hmm.
So what you're saying is that these algorithms that they use in order to
maximize their revenue and give people things that they like,
but actually takes away from things being posted chronologically,
keep certain things from being seen by as many people.
So it keeps him from being as viral,
so keeps the whole thing from being organic.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
It's,
uh,
it gets to that point where we're realizing that all of these things,
all these social media things are really recent.
We've only had them for a few years and we don't necessarily know what the rules
should or shouldn't be.
So it's good.
I mean,
it's one of the reasons why I wanted to have you on,
I wanted to find out where these upstarts or these new people are coming into
the game.
Like minds,
like where you're coming into the game from and what,
what is your position on what's wrong with the current state of affairs?
Yeah.
And look,
there is messed up stuff on social media.
Like I'm not,
we'll get pigeonholed into being like,
oh,
you support all of this,
this crazy stuff.
First of all,
most of the users on mines are like artists,
musicians,
filmmakers,
activists,
journalists,
just trying to get their content out there.
There's a very tiny minority of like actually,
you know,
crazy content.
But when you say crazy content,
what do you mean?
All right.
Yeah.
Or I mean,
I'm not even going to make decisions on what is and isn't crazy.
That's not,
that's not my place,
but
the,
it's been proven that censorship is not the answer.
I mean,
look at the history of prohibition.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
you have digital content,
it's substances,
it's,
it's anything from people want information and they want the ability to make the
decision for themselves.
They certainly do.
And then the argument on the other side is when people were distributing,
and I'm going to use the big air quotes,
hate speech,
that's when it gets slippery to me because who's to decide what's hate speech
and what's not hate speech.
I mean,
I've seen people make some ridiculous fucking statements about all sorts of
people that are inaccurate and they do that in order to categorize them and
pigeonhole them and an easily definable and dismissible care,
uh,
characterization,
you know,
and you just decide,
hey,
that Bill Ottman guy,
that guy's a this.
Oh,
he's a radical that and he believes in this,
so fuck him.
And they're like,
okay,
fuck cam,
sweep more.
I,
and then cancel culture comes in like,
we're going to cancel bill Ackman.
We're not listening to him anymore.
He lied to us about his source or whatever the fuck you doing.
Have you heard of Daryl Davis?
No,
I have not.
Most,
I forgot Dale Davis.
Your boy.
He's my boy.
He,
you'll,
I haven't met him,
but he's,
he's my boy.
I want him to be my boy.
So he is a black man who befriended hundreds of members of the KKK and he got
them all to leave.
He got them to leave the kid.
members.
Wow.
After he was like,
yeah,
I'm just gonna talk to you
really well.
Did you ever see the n a w Kamau Bell's a show when he visited with those white
supremacists?
Not that specific one.
Yeah,
it was really good because he's such a nice guy.
He's so like easy to get along with that.
They were like sort of like,
they let the guard down around them and you know,
you get to see these people kind of confused that they liked this guy.
You know?
That's why I think initiating human contact via the social networks,
like that's really important.
But to play devil's advocate,
it's one of the worst ways for people to express themselves in a way where you
consider other human beings experiences and feelings and the way they're going
to receive what you're saying because there's no social cues.
You're not interacting with them,
you're not looking at them in the eyes.
It's one of the weirder forms of communication between human beings and one that
I would argue we have not really necessarily a successfully navigated it yet.
I agree.
I was actually saying that I think we should use social media more to get people
to get together in real life.
Do you know who,
uh,
Megan Phelps's?
No,
she,
uh,
was a,
with the Westboro Baptist Church.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the famous one that the protests sows soldier's funerals and you know,
and,
and anything gay and they're like ruthlessly,
viciously fundamental Christians were,
you know,
they,
they do a lot of protesting at funerals and do a lot of stuff to try to get,
she was with them for the longest time and then got on Twitter and through
communicating on Twitter when you meet her,
you would never believe it in a million years that she was ever this
fundamentalist and that she was ever some mean person sending hateful messages
to people because their son was gay or whatever it was.
Now she's completely cured of it.
She has no contact with the church anymore.
She's married,
has a kid,
she completely outside of it.
She does podcasts now and give Ted talks and speaks about radicalization and
about how she was kind of indoctrinated in,
grew up in this family and her,
her grandfather,
Fred Phelps was this,
you know,
it's like,
it's a fucking mean guy.
Like a really mean Vishy.
He's the God hates fags guy.
You know,
they would have those signs that they would hold it up.
But at the soldier's funerals,
I mean,
he's like really inflammatory stuff,
but through Twitter,
through her communicating with people on Twitter and specifically her now
husband,
like he,
he cured her like it just with rational discourse and communication and she was
[inaudible] will change.
They will change.
And so that's why banning them.
I mean,
and you,
I saw on a recent podcast you've been talking about redemption.
Yeah.
So,
but I'm curious,
what do you,
do you think people,
what is,
how does that look like?
Well,
timber,
you look in the case of like Megan Phelps,
that's a real thing,
right?
She really did change.
Um,
another example is Christian peak Illini.
Do you know who he is?
He was a,
a white supremacists KKK member guy who's been on Sam Harris' podcast.
He's also done some Ted talks who now speaks out against it and talks about how
he's indoctrinated and talks about how lost he was.
Now he was brought into this ideology.
Um,
there are,
there's many people like that all over the world.
Um,
uh,
Magid,
Magid was another perfect example.
He was an Islamist,
I mean,
he was trying to form a caliphate,
was literally thinking about radical Islamic terrorism as being some sort of a
solution.
Now he's the opposite.
Now he's trying to get people to leave and he's trying to get people to be more
reasonable and secular and see what happened to him.
He ain't got punched in the street.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Some guy called him a fucking packy,
I guess,
and punched him in the head and fucked his head up and he's got this giant
cotton,
his head from a ring and his face is swollen up,
but apparently they have the guy on video and um,
you know,
they think that they're going to be able to arrest the guy I've had imagined on
the show.
He's a super nice guy.
The,
the hard thing is that all right.
Yes.
We see these transformations take place.
It makes us feel warm inside and yes,
people,
people can change,
but at the same time,
what are people have,
should people have to go apologize to Twitter?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Like,
can I come back?
Right.
I mean that's not like sometimes people are going to think completely
differently than you and you just have to deal with it and it,
that should be okay.
We,
we shouldn't force people to come in to our way of thinking in order to have
discourse.
No,
that's a good point.
That's a very good point.
Um,
and like who is to decide what this path to redemption is and whether or not
you've completed it,
right?
Who has decided like maybe you are a log,
a hyper radical lefty and maybe Jamie's points of view and yours are just never
going to line up.
So you're like,
fuck him.
He's banned for life,
which a lot of people had been banned for life and when you look at some of the
infractions,
they'd been banned for it.
They're like,
boy,
I don't know about that one.
That doesn't really make sense.
Almost none of the high pro profile banning cases make much sense.
No,
it's like a short term solution that's creating a longterm problem.
Yeah.
That's really what it is.
So I just think that we have to talk about it more.
I Dunno.
I,
it's like,
why can't we just get everyone to talk about it?
Yeah.
Like at the same time,
I mean,
it's like we're just wasting time here.
Well,
sort of,
but I also think we're figuring it out as we go along with a bunch of different
competing ideologies.
Um,
you know,
you have yours,
which like you dude,
you look like a hacker.
Unlike House of cards.
He looked like a guy you call in to break into the,
the,
the mainframe server.
Not that honestly.
I believe
you're not.
I,
I hang out on get lab in checkout co,
but I,
I cannot code.
Listen man,
I'm claiming I'm not claiming to be a developer.
No D's.
No,
you're not.
These people are,
I know there's another level.
Yeah,
it is incredible.
I understand.
Yeah,
I get it.
Well,
that's like,
if someone says to me like,
you're an MMA fighter,
I'm like,
I'm definitely not.
They are on another fucking level.
Like there's a different,
like,
yeah,
I know a little martial arts,
but just settle the fuck down.
Right?
Same kind of thing.
I think though that you,
your ideology is going to be your,
your point of view and perspectives going to be very different than maybe
someone who's like a radical Marxist,
you know,
it shouldn't they be allowed to post post on the site to someone who's like an
extreme socialist,
someone like a AOC.
You know,
someone,
someone who thinks that we should give money to people who are unwilling to
work,
someone who thinks that we should try to engineer society and tax the top x
percent,
you know,
70 something percent of their income.
There's a lot of those different people and we have to figure out how to,
to make it so that,
well,
we have to figure out a way to make it so all the ideas can compete in the
marketplace of ideas.
Right.
All these different ideas can compete and we can find out which one is better
and we can find out which one is better.
Yeah.
You don't always find out which one is better though.
Right.
You find out which one is most people?
I mean that's what happened with Hitler.
Right?
Or you don't really find out what's better.
You find out what,
what's got more juice behind it.
It's just,
it's too risky.
Even being in the position that I'm in,
you know,
I see these edge cases,
like we say,
look,
if it's legal it can be there.
But we still see edge cases where we have to make decisions.
What's like an edge case?
I mean,
let's say,
I mean there is,
I don't even want to go here,
but I will right there,
there is a type of animation.
Oh,
porn anomia yeah,
yeah.
That is very sketchy.
Uber,
you know,
like child porn,
animated child porn.
And we've taken the stance that,
look,
it's,
it could fall under obscenity laws.
So we don't,
we're not cool.
But you know,
that is a huge debate,
right?
That,
that,
that it has not been decided by the Supreme Court if animated,
you know,
kids like they will do the weirdest stuff.
And I,
I just don't want to be telling people what is and what is not art.
Right.
So like some of that Japanese stuff with tentacles,
like some of that stuff is just like,
what is happening here?
Like octopuses Bang and checks and every hole and they're choking on it and
they've got one in their ass and one of their vagina and it's all like very,
very liquidity.
You know,
there's a lot of splattering
going on.
You're like,
what the fuck is this?
And is that okay?
Because it's just art,
right?
I mean,
if it was a person getting fucked left,
right and center by an octopus,
he'd be like,
yeah,
I think we've crossed some lines here.
That's beastiality.
But if it's an image and if then,
then the image is a girl with a school girl costume on,
she's dressed like a Catholic school girl,
a little skirt,
and she's getting banged by an octopus.
Like what do you do with that?
Right?
Yeah.
What would you do?
It's a good question.
I'm glad I don't have a social media site where I have to make that decision.
Well,
the real concern would be,
is this something that is actually illegal?
That's the thing,
right?
And we,
we've tried to look at the case law and we've seen that this type of stuff has
been,
you know,
called obscenity.
Yeah.
Before.
And so we're just not going to risk it.
But I still,
you know,
in a alright,
nipples,
nipples look right.
Did you know that free the nipple started out fortune?
Well,
everywhere.
It's a whole,
it's a whole movement to be honest.
All right.
Time magazine just did a really interesting piece about a statue.
They got banned from Facebook and he was a naked ancient statue.
That's a nipple.
Like,
I'm sorry,
that's not,
that's not realistic that,
that,
that's not helping society taking down in a naked statue.
When we were talking about the other day,
uh,
during the Superbowl that a Adam Levine had his shirt off and Brian read,
Ben was like,
Hey,
d wasn't that like what Janet Jackson got in trouble for?
Like,
yeah.
Why does,
why is it okay if Adam Levine shows his nipples and Janet Jackson's nipples are
offensive because there's sexualized because she's a woman.
This is the weird fact.
Men had to gain the right to have their nipples shown in public back in the day.
When's the day I,
if you,
if you go on the free the nipple site,
there's this
go on their Instagram or something.
I think that's maybe where I saw it back when I used Instagram.
But
you know,
society is evolving.
We're going to get there,
we're going to be able to handle it I think or give people the controls so that
they can only see the types of things that they want to see.
That's ultimately what it's about.
So like you should have like a filter.
Like do I want 18 plus?
Do our want.
Um,
PG 13,
like what,
what kind of distinction do I want?
Yeah.
And then when,
when things come up,
like one of the things that Instagram has been doing is like they say,
I follow a lot of hunters and Instagram has things where they say,
warning,
this is a sensitive content.
Uh,
nature is metal gets popped on that a lot too because nature's metals and
Instagram side,
that's all like these crazy images and videos of animals eating other animals
and attacking their animals.
And sometimes some of them they just decide this one's too fucked up.
You know,
like just decide,
you know,
like this one of them where a lion is a looking out of
a,
a Willdabeast asshole.
Like from the inside.
Like this is giant hole.
They've eaten through its stomach and it's looking out.
It's asshole now like,
yeah,
this one you're going to have to click on your own.
You have to double click.
What do you got Jamie?
Basically from,
I just looked up,
Tarzan is the catalyst for why guys wanted to wear their shirts off.
They had like a 1920s,
19 terrorists they had to wear in pools.
They had to wear a top.
But look,
this is the only covers one mil.
Thus they're probably tired or sway or an alien right there.
That's how they started playing down the strap.
Look at it says here,
saucy lifeguards,
flash,
rebellious nipples.
Ah,
areas 37 that's hilarious.
So it was Tarzan 1937 in New York state's male shirtless ban.
That's when they overturned it.
The incident attracted press attention as Atlantic city,
other waterfronts similarly mandated against men.
Nips.
Would that legal domino tipped along with the help of Hollywood hunks.
And you were talking about how their Twitter has porn.
Yes.
Yo,
a lot banned from Google play for that.
Twitter has it.
They're up on Google play is Twitter has a substantial amount of porn.
You know,
you follow like some of them gals and they just wanted you to see,
look,
here's one of the my pussy right there.
Take a look like full blown.
Not Offensive.
Well it's not offensive.
You've,
you've followed them.
I mean if you follow certain porn stars in terms,
Oh really?
But they're just allowing it because they know they want that traffic.
Oh,
is that what it is?
They want that traffic,
that traffic bro.
Yeah.
Um,
it's a problem if you hand your phone to your kid accidentally click on that
link and I'm like,
Mommy,
what's happening?
Her?
But Jonathan Haidt Haidt her height,
height,
height.
He was talking about an interesting thing where,
you know,
it should there be an age where we really get into social media.
I don't know.
I mean people should be free with free to do what they want to do,
but you know,
the Internet is,
is the wilderness,
well his book,
the coddling of the American mind,
uh,
I'm,
I'm in that right now.
I just finished his other one and I'm working on that one.
And a lot of it has to do with social media and a lot of it has to do with the
impact that it has on young people.
You know,
people are not really designed for this and you might be able to handle it if
your 32 year old man or a 35 year old woman or whatever you are.
But if you're a 15 year old girl,
this might,
it might be overwhelming.
I mean,
and the,
the angst and the anxiety and you know,
wanting to,
I was saying about the,
the depression,
you know,
they see if they're not at a party or their stuff's not getting liked,
that has an impact on them.
And ultimately I think the networks need to be helping educate people how to,
you know,
whether it's this info,
educate people how to research.
I did see that youtube is starting to do like a,
you've been on this for too long type thing.
Really?
Yeah.
Like get a life you fuck yeah.
They tell you that I want to build stuff like that.
That that's really important.
Yeah.
Helping people get off.
I haven't,
I haven't seen that.
I haven't done enough time on youtube where they're kicking me off.
I have,
it's easy.
You know,
I was uh,
I sent,
uh,
Eddie Bravo,
this thing from the Guardian about,
uh,
the upsurge in people that believe in the flat earth and all of it because of
youtube videos and that apparently now youtube is,
they want to censor those.
They want to,
uh,
they,
they feel like flat earth videos and uh,
I think another one,
check this check gives this if I'm wrong about this,
but I think they also want to lean on those anti-vaccination videos.
I think there's a concern with those.
I think they're worried about a bunch of different things along those lines.
You know,
like they feel like there's disinformation and outright lies that are being
spread.
How do we combat it?
We own this platform.
What do we do?
They feel like they have a responsibility.
I think there is responsibility.
Okay,
but what is the responsibility?
If there's a debate,
I think it's more to educate people how to research as opposed to saying this is
or is not true.
Right?
Because who's deciding that?
Well,
I believe the earth is round,
but uh,
um,
I also believe it's such a stupid conspiracy that you should have it.
You should be allowed and it should be something you should show your friends.
Like,
dude,
I need you to go look at this.
This has 37,000 thumbs up.
And they really believe that the fucking earth is flat.
They really believe there's an ice wall outside Antarctica.
They really believe that the sky doesn't move.
That it's that the,
you know,
that we're in some sort of a,
I think it's like projected images or something.
Like there's a bunch of like really,
really wacky theories.
Like I think those are okay.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
But I think freedom of information sort of transcends a lot of these little
debates.
So if there was more freedom of information so we actually knew everything the
government knew about all of the different conspiracies and black projects,
the black budget.
Yeah.
More information is going to get both sides.
The ability to understand what is happening.
That's true.
The reality is that we don't know what's happening and there is lots of secret
stuff.
The problem with that though is then you're dealing with foreign governments
that are way better at keeping secrets than we are.
And if they have access to our secrets,
like one of the things that's been kind of disturbing is seeing the actual
influence of these Russian troll farms have had on not just our political
process,
but sowing seeds of descent amongst people and,
and starting
conflict amongst people and how people are buying into it.
You know,
like this a podcast I've been talking about a lot with Sam Harris and Renee
[inaudible],
that's her name,
right.
Um,
where they talked about how these Russian troll farms set up a conflict by
having a pro Muslim rally across the street from a pro Texas pride rally.
And they just set it all up and had it there.
And then a skirmish broke out because these people are across the street from
each other and that they do this with,
they were having these African American groups that were seeing anyone but
Hillary and they were going to like try really trying to get people to vote for
Jill Stein.
Really trying to get people to even consider Trump,
but anyone but Hillary and then you,
they were also having like ones that were against them.
They're trying to like make debate to trying to make anger and they don't think
you can stop that.
But it's a fascinating thing,
isn't it?
That this is like a concerted effort.
Yeah.
Like how do you feel about that when you say,
when you are,
you know,
you're in a position where you have a fairly small network,
but it's influential.
Right.
And then see watching Zuckerberg and the Facebook shit on TV and they're talking
to these congresspeople and senators and they're talking to all these
politicians about what's going on and how to stop it and what they're trying to
do.
And,
and you feel like,
Oh God,
like this is kind of a,
this is an arena that I'm getting it
to.
What would you do?
I mean,
I think more conversation needs to happen now less.
Yeah.
So I think you're right.
I just,
I want more information.
I want from the government,
from the corporations,
from the trolls,
from the trolls.
I mean,
yeah,
I,
you know,
I feel like I have a pretty good ability to discern what is and is not troll
behavior.
I think help people understand how,
how to read,
how to absorb information.
Like just banning an account that is trying to,
has an agenda is everyone has an agenda.
It's a propaganda back and forth between everybody.
I don't,
I mean,
just because somebody posts a Jill Stein meme.
Okay,
what's your point?
Like their intention.
Okay.
I'm not saying that,
you know,
regime change behavior is positive and negative.
I don't know how we sort of switch gears.
No,
we did,
but let,
let me,
let me step in here.
When you,
when you're saying a Jill Stein meme,
there's absolutely nothing wrong with you posting a Jill Stein meme.
Like say if you have a joke about Jill Stein,
you wanted to post it in a meme.
There's nothing wrong with that.
What's weird for people is that people were being hired to make these memes and
they,
these memes may not have anything to do with her own personal ideology.
They must just might just decide,
hey,
I'm going to collect this check and I'm going to end.
They make apparently according to Renee and this podcast you did with Sam
Harris,
they make really hilarious memes.
Like some of them are really fun.
I listen to that podcast.
Yeah,
it was great.
She said that she,
she started laughing.
Yeah.
And she,
you know,
she had to go through thousands and thousands of them.
That's weird.
There's this idea of a web of trust,
which is interesting.
Sort of like a peer to peer.
It's not like a Chinese social score,
but it's like if you,
the people that you're connected with
show a certain account to be untrustworthy,
then you know,
because you trust your little network.
So there it's sort of like a peer to peer score.
We were looking at different ideas.
I think that
transparency and understanding what's going on with different accounts and if
it's the real person,
that's all important stuff.
We don't,
we don't want frauds,
we don't want to send foe,
but you know,
we just have to really step back and think about how we're doing it rather than
letting AI and algorithms run the show.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
Um,
do you think that there is a,
I don't want to say there's a market,
is there a demand for this?
Like are a lot of people responding in a positive way to the way you guys are
approaching the game?
Yeah,
for sure.
Every time there's a big scandal every time,
whether it's,
you know,
data manipulation or,
our first big growth spurt was during the Snowden days when he released all the
information,
right.
People are really upset with what's happening.
It's just,
you know,
where are they supposed to do?
Like this is what they're using for their communication.
It's not easy to just achieve,
you know,
a multibillion person network overnight so that everybody's there and so we're
stuck.
But again,
I think that supplementing just installing these alternative apps,
not just us,
it's like the whole open source market.
I'm not even here trying to just talk about what we're doing right.
It's like if you don't have those apps on your phone and you don't use those
browsers,
I'm sorry,
you just,
you're not helping.
And people just want to vote with their energy,
I think,
and vote with their time.
So it's more of an education thing.
People just don't know that this matters and that this can help change the whole
Internet simply by logging into an app once in a while.
It's like,
it's,
it's like organic food.
I mean we want to put things into it.
We want to support things to have integrity.
So when you click something,
you are supporting that thing.
When you're sitting on an app all day,
you are feeding that APP.
That's how the apps get all the money.
That's where they get all their funding.
That's that.
That's where it's all based,
is in user retention and energy.
And do you think that most people were even aware of this?
Do you think they're just using it because it's convenient?
The biggest shariah going on right now?
Most people don't know that Facebook owns Instagram.
They think Instagram's like cool because you know it's Facebook,
right?
It's one giant umbrella.
Yeah.
Um,
what is,
what is the difference between the two?
Obviously with Instagram it's just pictures mostly.
And then whatever the post is below the pictures.
But with Facebook it's a lot more commentary and long verbose statements on
Shit.
And then people arguing in the comments about it.
[inaudible]
yeah,
they're all the Instagram founders left abandoned ship.
The whatsapp founders abandoned ship,
the oculus founder abandoned ship,
all because of the privacy stuff.
Really?
They're like,
you took this good thing.
Well,
it was proprietary.
So I would argue if it was ever actually a fully good thing,
but at least it wasn't,
you know,
completely corrupted by Facebook.
But all of the founders of those companies left because they hate what's going
on.
What the whatsapp guy joined signal,
which is a really cool opensource anti and encrypted messaging APP.
So you know,
these people know to what happened with whatsapp.
It's not the same anymore.
WHATSAPP is owned by Facebook.
I don't know this.
Oh sorry.
Hey,
come on Bro.
Get with a gang of jungle man.
Well you're deep into this man.
That's why I want to talk to you.
Yeah.
It's,
and they're all buying up companies and,
and using the same sort of ideas.
Yeah.
Now they're talking about integrating the messages between what?
WHATSAPP,
Instagram and Facebook.
So it's all one system rule.
Yeah.
Centralization.
It has happened.
It hasn't been turned on yet,
but I believe it's happening.
Like,
doesn't like your dms on Instagram.
You're going to have to download the Facebook messenger.
So what is,
what are the challenges for something like minds,
uh,
when you,
you're trying to take off,
like there was a,
uh,
social media Instagram type thing that was around a little while ago.
I remember I used it like once and I posted about it and what was that called?
But then Vero,
is that what it was?
But then a lot of people were saying it was bullshit and they're proprietary,
which you don't know.
It's closed source.
No idea what's going on behind the scenes.
Same as the other one.
A lot of apps try to say that there are alternatives and that,
you know,
they support x,
Y and z.
No privacy or free speech or whatnot.
But
I don't think it's any new paradigm if they're not showing their source code so
that people can see the algorithms,
the people who care.
You know,
obviously most people aren't going to go and inspect the code,
but just the principle that the experts could cause they will,
you know,
there's all kinds of think tanks and whatnot that they would love to dive into
the source code to understand how these companies were actually behaving.
So,
you know,
waving the privacy flag without being open source or this is getting a little
bit into the weeds,
but a lot of this comes down to licensing of,
of content or code.
So the,
the license that we use for our code is called the general public license,
the Agpl v three,
which means that anyone can take our code and do whatever they want with it.
They can sell it,
they can do anything,
but if they make changes,
they have to show them with everybody else.
So it's sort of like,
uh,
the creative Commons,
Cheryl like license,
which is essentially says the same thing.
Take my video photo,
remix it,
do whatever you want,
but you have to share the result with everybody else.
Open source basically means you can do whatever you want with it.
You can take it,
make it your own,
you know,
keep your own little secret sauce of what makes you feel good.
They get conflated because you know free software sounds like free as in free
beer,
not free as in freedom.
So you know,
licensing is really what this all coalesces into [inaudible] and it's been
proven that you can make a lot of money with free and open source software.
I mean look at wordpress,
it's a hugely successful technology corporation and multibillion dollars people
share the code.
That's how it,
it created a network effect because they did that.
It's like the grateful dead would let everybody record their music and how it
spreads.
So it's actually a good marketing tactic and it also gives transparency so
people can see what the hell is going on right now.
When you started this,
what,
what was your objective and where are you thinking about it as a potential large
scale source of revenue or were you just thinking this is something that I would
like to do and do correctly because I don't think anybody's doing it this way.
Open source,
you know,
pro censorship or pro a freedom of speech anticensorship and to,
to just do the bare minimum amount of managing content.
I think everyone should be able to make money.
I don't think it should have to be mutually exclusive.
Like you do something for free for everybody and you also can't make money.
That's a big misconception.
We're trying to give people the tools to make money.
I mean I w w we have like a monthly recurring subscription system,
sort of like a crypto patrion type tool so you can subscribe to people.
We had the ability for creators to accept Fiat dollars,
but we took it out because it's stripe and stripe is a closed source system,
which we just didn't have longterm faith in.
So stripe was a,
and some sort of an extension to your site if we were using their API to
facilitate peer to peer payments.
Oh,
this is why I'm really patrion most likely band Carl because Argon of a car Gunn
who,
um,
yeah,
because the payment processors went to them or like,
look,
you know,
stripe has strict terms
and we didn't want to be,
you know,
talking to straight.
Like we don't want to be subject to overlords in our company decisions.
So you know,
you think that that's what happened with Carl that is most likely what happened.
So they stepped in and said,
hey,
we don't want this guy to be a part of the site.
Yeah.
And I think that stripe probably stepped in with a lot of explicit content,
controversial content.
I mean,
it's in their policy that you can't facilitate payments dealing with that type
of content.
And now we're seeing banks actually go,
go after people.
Well the thing about Carl doe was that his content that there was questionable,
wasn't even related to patriarch had nothing to do with it.
It was on another person's podcast.
It was from six months prior and that other person's podcast was on youtube.
It had nothing to do with patron.
And they had specifically said that they were not going to act on content that
was outside of their network.
They were only going to react to things that were on Patrion.
Right.
Cause you can make little blogs and stuff on Patrion.
They do have some content.
Yeah.
So,
but that's not what patron said.
Obviously the processors,
Pr,
I don't want to,
who knows.
Yeah.
I didn't want to act like,
I also don't want it to seem like I have an ideology that I'm trying to push
right now.
Like I'm very open to moving in the direction that makes the most sense for the
community.
I'm not,
I'm not attached to what I'm thinking.
Good.
So I liked that.
I wish,
I wish more people would do that.
That,
I mean I tried to do that.
I'm really getting way better at it,
but it's something I actively work on.
Like these ideas that I have,
I'm not fucking married them.
Don't argue them.
Look at them,
look at them.
And if someone says something different,
go,
Huh.
All right.
They'll go,
no man.
All right.
I brought bro.
You know,
cause that,
that natural instinct to argue and to claim some sort of a personal identity
with your,
uh,
with your ideas.
That's,
that's part of the problem that we have.
Yeah,
I think it's,
it's a main conflict issue with social media is one of the things that I see a
lot of that,
look,
I used to do it way back in the day.
If you go back to the early days of Twitter,
I used to argue with people.
I used to argue with people on social media.
Then I realized some long time ago,
like there is no good that comes out of that.
I might correct someone if someone said something that's incorrect,
but I'm not going to argue and I'm not going to insult.
And um,
I just,
I'm just not,
I don't even,
doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
It just makes people argue back and insult your back and nothing ever gets
accomplished.
Occasionally a dunk on people and it's fun.
But Rhea,
in reality,
especially me,
I mean,
I kind of dunk on people for a living.
So I'm just gonna,
I'm not going to engage and I don't,
this is going to sound corny as fuck.
I don't want to hurt anybody's feelings.
I really don't.
I don't want to be in some argument where someone is looking at their phone
like,
fucking fuck you.
Fuck you.
I don't want that.
I get that.
I know what it is.
I know what it is,
but it's,
it's in this flat medium.
Okay.
This two dimensional medium of typing,
text and then sending taxed and you type tax and San taxed,
the conflict that arises through that is never beneficial in my opinion.
I don't get anything out of it.
So what,
you know,
if I'm expressing something,
almost always,
uh,
try to express something about shit I like,
like,
Oh,
I love this new show.
All this movie was great.
Oh,
this is amazing.
Like check out this picture.
You might want to check this out.
It's,
it's tone.
Yeah.
Honestly,
like I,
I,
same with me.
Like I was much more trying to convince people about what I thought was right.
You know,
coming out of college,
you think you're all high and mighty.
It doesn't work.
People just,
you know,
are allergic to I'm allergic to,
I cannot handle it.
Like it's not,
no one wants to to talk like that.
It's one thing if you're having a good time.
Yeah.
And trying to just like show someone up.
And,
and it just,
you can have fun with it.
It's more comedic.
But when you're actually taking yourself seriously,
like it's not going to work.
No.
It's not going to work.
And it actually has the exact opposite effect.
That's like,
um,
the expression,
what w how's expression?
Like a jealousy is like a poison.
That,
how does it go?
Jealousy is like a poison that you take yourself because you don't like what
someone else's accomplishing.
I forget the terrible job paraphrase Matt and I,
my,
my worst paraphrasing of all time mumble mouth motherfucker than I am.
But uh,
but the idea is that it has the exact opposite effect.
Like [inaudible] jealous about someone that actually makes you feel bad instead
of them feel bad.
It also makes them not want to hang out with you.
Well,
you know,
they probably don't want hanging out with you anyway,
let's be honest.
But,
but the,
the,
you know what you're doing by back and forth on.
So I know,
and I know people who do engage in it and sometimes they have these,
uh,
anxiety moments where they don't sleep for days because they're involved in
these Twitter feuds.
I mean,
I know people that have done this where they've gotten involved in Twitter feuds
in,
they'll wake up three o'clock in the morning to check their Twitter feed and
like,
oh Christ man,
like you gotta go,
go,
uh,
go on a yoga retreat or something.
Like,
he can't do this.
You can't live your life like this.
I think there may be some value to the debate.
Have it should be there.
It's just be there debate and it's like,
okay,
I'm not going to spend my time doing it that way.
Some people want to spend their time doing it that way.
And if there's cool mechanisms for,
you know,
the most voted content to be seen.
So the,
I mean,
okay,
that's interesting to check out sometimes too,
to look at feedback,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
it's not nearly as an effective way of communicating your ideas as like making
something more personal.
It's more,
I mean,
even video is,
is,
is more effective than that because people actually
have a chance to look at you or obviously in person.
Yeah.
You met her.
Well,
in person is obviously the best.
Um,
and I think my concern really about the futures.
I'm holding back a sneeze right now.
Sorry.
I'm trying to keep it together.
I don't think I can,
it's one of those borderline ones.
What he's supposed to do.
Suppose stare at the light.
Are you trying to resist?
Nah,
I'm trying to get,
okay.
We're good.
We're out of the woods.
Um,
uh,
I lost my train of thought.
What was it?
What were we just saying?
Hey,
I something,
no jealousy quote.
You're talking to your,
we want to get past that.
And Jamie,
I know we for days I was looking for it and then
I lost it.
I lost it in my,
uh,
holding back a sneeze that,
oh,
that's what I was worried about Ai.
I'm not AI augmented reality.
That's what I'm really worried about.
Not Artificial but augmented.
And uh,
Mike,
my concern is at what we're experiencing right now in this flat form of two
dimensional taxed is something that is very overwhelming to a lot of people's
time.
And you're looking at some kids that are online social media,
eight,
10 hours a day just staring at their phones.
Um,
I'm extremely concerned and I have some jokes about it in my act about the next
wave because I think that we are overwhelmed by this incredibly attractive
medium where we're,
we're attracted to,
our phones were attracted to this style of engaging and information,
receiving information and passing it from it.
And then an online arguments and debates and,
and looking at pictures and this constant stream,
which,
you know,
just looking at your phone,
it's not that thrilling.
It's just like,
hmm.
It's not that thrilling and just like,
okay,
yeah,
but it's still getting you all day long.
Like there's nothing really crazy happening when my concern is if something
really crazy does start to happen,
when you really can have experiences that are a hyper normal like that are that
are more powerful than anything you can experience in this regular carbon based
physical touch and feel world.
And once we start experiencing augmented reality,
the integration between humans and technology and then the ability to share
augmented reality like to shit.
Like if you were at work and you have these fucking goggles on and your
girlfriend is at work on the other side of town and you,
you guys both have like these similar video pets that are with you and dancing
around and providing you with fucking advertisements and giving you things
there.
There's,
there's next levels to this stuff that I'm trying to like see the future,
but I'm too fucking stupid and I don't really know anything about technology,
but I know that they're going to get deeper into our lives.
I know that these technologies,
not they liked the government,
but these technologies,
they're going to get deeper into your life and that they got you by the balls
and the clit with a fucking phone
and it doesn't even do much.
Take some pictures,
look at some pictures,
look at some text,
watch some videos.
That's all it does and access to most human knowledge.
That's true,
but how many people are using that?
Right?
Was He,
you know,
they are for sure.
They definitely are.
There's a lot of googling going on.
I'm sorry,
what does the other one just duck,
duck,
go,
go and going on.
I,
I'm holding out for fair.
Another one,
and we might start working on search more being as a god damn ghost town,
isn't it?
I bet if you go to bing,
you got to blow fucking dust off your keyboard as soon as you open it up like no
one's in there.
Who's in bing?
Bang is just Microsoft's.
I know,
but who's who's using that?
Oh ladies.
I think that youtube is the number two search engine on the web.
Youtube.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's what really makes so many videos about somebody weird topics and it's
just like,
oh,
it'll pop up and you get,
I don't think we can stop it,
but you know,
cause look,
it would be fun to,
you know,
the,
with the frequency that you go to like an arcade.
Like I would go and do some crazy ar,
VR stuff.
I mean it would be fun.
It's like a rare entertainment thing to do.
I just want to make sure that like see even with the robots that we're carrying
around now do is,
is it respecting my freedom is this thing on my side?
It's not,
I don't think it is right now because I'm using android is open source.
Are you an android guy?
Of course you will.
Yeah.
But all this crypto guys,
they're all android.
It's just more freedom.
But now Google's version of android is just as bad as ILS whose version of
android to use.
I am,
yeah.
I'm,
no,
I'm not telling him,
I'm not perfect.
I'm on,
I'm on the Google android right now,
but there's a version called replicant,
which is,
which is a fully free version of android that I'm probably,
because I just cracked my phone like a day ago,
so I might get a new one.
What do you use him?
What phone do you use as eight?
Oh,
look at you.
Yeah,
kind of retro.
Is it like a year ago,
there's this one called the black phone,
which I'm looking into,
which is,
it's like a hyper encrypted phone,
but I don't know.
I don't know if it's,
if it's fully free.
So isn't there a blockchain based phone that there were coming out with and the
theory and base phone?
Isn't that,
I don't know.
Isn't that something Jamie?
Sure.
I definitely got announced,
but I don't know that it's still in development.
You can't run everything on a blockchain?
No.
Blockchains are pretty slow.
Um,
we,
we use it even to publish to the ethereum blockchain.
Like when you send each other payments on mines,
it costs like,
you know,
there's a gas fee.
So the way that the network is powered is that the miners get paid with gas with
a little bit of ether.
So cost like a buck to do a post.
Like there's fully decentralized social networks.
There's one called a PP,
which you have to pay for everything you do right on on it.
And so this is why it's,
it's a cool experiment,
but it's really not scalable.
So you know,
it's gonna be a combination of,
of decentralized technology.
Like not just blockchain.
People like to,
you know,
say the blockchain is going to solve all the problems and it's,
it's gonna solve a lot of problems.
It's an incredible tool.
But yeah,
I am a,
what does this,
Jamie,
is this it the Finney one that's out now?
Yeah,
just,
just what I'm saying,
like a month ago or pretty siren.
Oh,
s which I'm not exactly what does that jazz,
good luck getting the fucking app with that.
Then in some of those android apps,
they're,
they're sneaky,
right?
Don't they steal bitcoin?
There was an android app that,
uh,
got in trouble for stealing cryptocurrency.
It was a stealing it in the background.
While you,
while you had your app open and it was on the Google play store.
See if that's true.
I'm not have made something up.
I could get sued.
I don't think I did though.
I think it might've been mining and I think it was stealing.
Yeah,
we'll pull that up so we could see it.
Um,
I have an android phone as well.
I have a note nine.
I really like it.
It's giant.
Huge screen.
Great battery life.
Beautiful.
So you use both?
Yes.
Bitcoin scam warning over fake android APP that steals cryptocurrency from your
phone.
Yeah,
I use both.
Um,
Andrew is very good now.
It's very good.
I,
I was an early adopter and it was like clunky and shitty and then I would go to
my iPhone.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is so much better.
What?
Iphone is great with his integration with like Apple TV integration with a
laptop.
But I also have a windows laptop that I use a lot of.
I really like a,
I have a Lenovo think pad for,
as for writing the keyboards better.
In fact,
I actually bought an older Mac book just for the keyboard because as a writer
you,
you want tactile feedback as you're writing.
It just helps.
It makes it easier for you to recognize where the keys are.
And Apple has decided to go so far towards design and just for aesthetic beauty
that they've ruined the tactile feedback to you.
Remember that though when the old smart phones,
you could,
they still had the keyboard.
I thought I would never leave that because he's tactile.
Right?
Ultimately left.
That's true.
But that's a different experience.
That's just yams.
I can do that with my thumbs and I kind of know where everything is and I'm not
writing a novel.
You know,
when I'm writing a material or essays or something like that,
I need,
I need a fucking keyboard.
You don't think that the holographic screen that's just here,
you don't think if it just like auto corrects everything you do and you could
just like maybe,
but there's,
there's a,
I liked the tactile too.
I'm just,
there's a feeling I like mechanical keyboards.
In fact,
there's a feeling of knowing.
Could you,
did you test out that facetime bug?
Can you hear about face time bug and there was a facetime bug where?
What was it?
You didn't see that?
I heard about it,
but I didn't look into it at all.
We didn't test it out and play with basically you could call someone and hear
them without them picking up.
Oh yeah.
Without
them picking up.
Then picking it up.
Yeah,
so the thing is ringing on facetime and they don't even have to pick up and then
you're on the other end talking shit about them.
Yeah.
He's basically surveil anybody,
Bill and fuck minds.
That guy's full of shit.
As soon as the big companies come to him,
he's going to stick his ass in the air just like all of them to the camera can
be turned on to make sense.
I was thinking about that when I'm beating off,
don't you?
You should.
They,
apple acts like it cares about privacy,
which maybe it doesn't turn certain overthinks the FBI,
I don't know exactly what's,
but we don't know what the apple phones are doing.
Right.
Apple is all locked down,
closed source.
And additionally there was a creepy speech that Tim Cook just just gave creepy.
Did you see it?
No.
Let's listen to it.
Yeah,
let's listen to his show.
He plays folky music,
Adl speech.
Do you have any spooky music you could play in the background while he's doing
the speech?
We might get in trouble for that.
So again,
it's good intentions.
Like people who want less hate speech,
we all want less h beach.
Of course we want people to get along better.
Right?
But this idea that I don't want to give too much away,
but you know,
he's acting as if they are going to be the moral authority about the types of
content that can exist on the APP store.
Yeah.
So I just don't know how that's scalable.
What does that mean?
Like let's hear what here.
I was just hoping this is the right one is,
is it?
It says CEO Tim Cook Banning Hate Division is the right thing to do.
12 three,
2018 is that it?
December.
That's it.
Okay.
Let's hear it.
Hello,
Tim.
Volume please.
Devices connected to the humanity that makes us us.
We do that in many ways.
What are the most important is how we honor a teaching that can be found in
Judaism,
but is shared across all faiths and traditions.
It's a lesson that was carried forward by the late Elie Rizal.
May his memory be a blessing.
It's a lesson put into practice by America's Muslim community who raised
thousands for the victims of the tree of life killings,
Lowe,
Tom Mode.
I'll dom ray ACA.
Do not be indifferent to the bloodshed of your fellow man.
Do not be indifferent.
This mandate moves us to speak up for immigrants and for those who seek
opportunity in the United States.
We do it not only because they're individual dignity,
creativity,
and ingenuity,
the power to make this country and even better place,
but because our own humanity commands us to welcome those who knew need welcome.
It moves us to speak up for the Lgbtq community for those whose differences can
make them a target for violence and scorn.
We do so.
Not only because these unique and uncommon perspectives can open our eyes to new
ways of thinking,
but because our own dignity moves us to see the dignity and others,
perhaps most importantly,
it drives us not to be bystanders.
Bystanders,
as hate tries to make its headquarters in the digital world
and apple,
we believe that technology needs to have a clear point of view on this
challenge.
There is no time to get tied up in knots.
Okay?
That's why we only have one message for those who seek to push hate division and
violence.
Yeah.
You have no place on our platforms.
[inaudible]
you have no home here from the earliest days of Itunes to apple music today.
We have always prohibited music with a message of white supremacy.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Um,
what,
what do you think they're signaling here?
Like are they signaling that they're about to start censoring things?
Like what do they already,
are they okay?
I agree.
The shit you probably shouldn't put white supremacy music on,
but there's a lot of like really violent stuff that you can get on iTunes.
Right?
I mean if you go back to the old Nwa albums,
there's some that's available,
right?
Sure.
I guess I would,
I'm assuming.
Yeah,
that it is for sure.
But yeah,
like straight Outta Compton,
uh,
some violin shit.
And then how about the films that they have?
How about the films that you can get on the iTunes store?
There is a lot of very,
very,
very violent films,
like extremely violent.
There's a lot of films that like,
is it that they're making the distinction between something that's fiction that
although it may be disturbing,
you understand that this is a movie and this is something someone wrote versus
someone art versus versus someone with commentary,
their commentary say.
And then here's the other thing.
Well he was saying hate and division.
They won't promote division,
but that's a weird one.
Yeah.
That means like,
what does that mean?
People who disagree with you and what does division has good intentions.
You can sort of steal it.
Yeah.
The problem with this,
that it's,
he's not allowing the conversation to take place.
So this is in direct conflict with the Daryl Davises with confronting these
issues so we can kill it.
But I think,
uh,
w w when,
when he's saying you have no place on our platform,
they probably feel like you can go somewhere else.
He's building a wall.
Yeah.
I mean,
but this is what I'm saying,
like everybody kind of feels like you can go somewhere.
That's what happens though.
And that's how things get more radicalized and everybody goes to Gab.
So I don't know.
Look,
the conversation needs to take place.
People on the lap,
he,
he's acting like he's speaking for all Lgbtq people.
Yeah.
He's not,
there's lots of people on the left and Lgbtq people aren't always on the left,
and not all of them want that.
Well,
not only that,
there's division in LBG,
t and Q,
like there's a,
there's a big issue right now with Martina Navratilova that was going on about
her discussing the reality of Trans Women competing against biological women and
that she opposes it and she thinks is there some fundamental advantages,
which is leading to a lot of weightlifting world records being broken by Trans
Women.
And she's like,
this is fucking preposterous.
And including Trans Women with penises,
now they're attacking her for being trans phobic.
So there's not even a United and United opinion in the Lbgtq community for sure.
And that's why that uh,
Megan Murphy I think,
yes,
the,
I go to this restaurant in Bridgeport,
Connecticut called blood root,
which is like sort of an old school feminist like vegetarian Vegan spot and in
Bridgeport.
In Bridgeport.
Bridgeport,
yeah.
Kind con.
No,
no offense.
I know it's kind of a dot.
Wild place.
We would have a gathering of the vibes,
music festivals.
I helped organize,
I used to do stand up in Bridgeport and I said,
please call the joker's wild.
It was a comedy club.
So only beat a guy with a shoe there,
a beat a guy in the face with a shoe,
pull the shoe off and to intervene.
I was 24 I know what the fuck was going on.
So anyway,
though,
that restaurant that you know,
they get called,
um,
what is it?
Turf Turfs.
Yeah.
Trans exclusionary radical feminist.
And so again,
you know,
they're the old school ones and they're saying,
look,
you know,
we're not against your,
your battle.
We're not against trans rights.
I mean,
who,
who would be against trans?
But they're just saying that's not our thing.
So again,
there's diversity and they're trying to clump everyone together and the whole
intersectional world.
And I look,
people want to band together.
The oppressed groups want to band together.
They should.
Yeah.
But like,
it's not that simple.
Well,
there's always going to be
differing opinions.
And especially when you have something like,
you know,
Trans Women competing against biological women and you know,
you have someone like Martina Navratilova that made her,
her life's work and her career competing as a biological woman.
Um,
she's gonna have some opposition to that.
And then the idea that everyone's supposed to be lumped in together with some
mandate that no one has really openly discussed and you're supposed to agree and
it fluctuates and moves like the tide,
you know,
like what is in his and moves like the Todd,
it just changes.
It's like this court of public opinion.
It's,
it's constantly rendering new verdicts and you,
you have to keep up and catch up.
Things that were acceptable just a few years ago are totally unacceptable.
It mean comedy is,
is the key area too.
Yeah.
It is not what,
what's happening on social media now.
Not Sustainable for comedy because it's fine.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
How?
Because it creates outrage and then comedy,
it relieves that pressure.
Like,
believe me,
there's a lot of blow back and believe me,
there's a lot of debate and discussion,
but also,
believe me,
when someone does do some politically incorrect,
really good,
stand up people go fucking bonkers.
They love it.
It's going,
it's like one of the best times ever right now to do stand up.
People go fucking April.
Yeah,
no,
it's incredible material.
But I'm just saying for you know,
comics that are running into issues with getting banned or when not,
I mean,
well,
who's running into issues with getting banned?
I mean,
I think,
you know,
one Oh,
when,
yeah,
yeah.
Owens had some issues.
Yeah.
Um,
and you know,
you could make some arguments at Owens not doing so well right now.
Um,
but he's also developing his following because of the factors.
People that don't agree with him being banned.
He's,
he's a very specific example.
Um,
other people that are being banned.
Do you know of,
uh,
other who,
what other standup comedians and a bunch of comics on,
maybe they haven't been fully band from social media,
but they've had their performances,
uh,
shutdown.
Who was that one guy who was like,
oh,
new mash.
Tell,
but that was at a college.
See,
do the same.
It's the same thing.
Yes.
But universities have been bad for that for a long time.
Uh,
they're the most sensitive of all audiences and they're the ones who are the
most,
uh,
they believe the most,
that they're going to change the world and that their ideals are there,
their ideals are rock solid and they have to push back against anything that
opposes them.
Ari was temporarily banned.
That was an accident.
Yeah.
The Ra thing was he was joking around and they thought he was making legitimate
death threat.
Could it,
that could happen,
but joking around with a good friend of ours,
the,
the algorithms are our key in the moderators are just not right.
We can't
just be having this happen all the time and then they just keep saying,
oh,
sorry,
sorry.
There has to be a new approach completely.
It can't just be,
oh,
let them back on and,
and just keep doing what they're doing.
Like we need to completely reapproach how moderation is happening.
The whole policies situation,
the transparency situation.
It's not just a matter of
going to the overlords and saying,
Hey,
can I,
can I please come back?
Right.
It's,
that's not,
that's not suitable for the communication structure of the planet earth.
Well,
I think what's not suitable is that commerce should not dictate how human beings
are allowed to openly communicate with each other.
And one of the things that Jack said that's kind of contrary to his company's
actions was that he believes that the ability to communicate as a fundamental
right,
like the ability to get electricity.
Like if you're in the KKK,
you could still order electricity,
you know?
So should you be able to just distribute information if people say no,
then you have to say,
okay,
well who's to decide what can and cannot be distributed?
And then who's to decide if they can go somewhere else.
And then what happens if you tell a person they can't go anywhere,
then things get really weird.
We're looking at more of a
community moderation structure so that we've even been considering like a juror
system so that if we make a bad decision in someone appeals it,
then the community can potentially make the decisions as opposed to us or you
know.
But then when you go further enough for far enough into the decentralization
world,
it just becomes impossible.
So we sort of have to decide.
I think that's where it's going to go.
So
I don't know.
I don't,
that's,
that's the uncensorable Internet and this idea that we can do things and then
just delete them.
Like in the Gdpr,
the European privacy laws have this whole idea of the right to be forgotten
online,
which is very difficult because deleting things from any database,
specially a blockchain is not easy.
So the idea that you can go on the internet,
do crazy shit,
and then just have it taken away.
It's a paradox because privacy means control,
but you know,
it,
it doesn't jive with the way that technology works to just be able to delete
things like you're writing to a database that's not even how the universe
probably really works.
Like you can't just say,
oh,
I just went and punched that guy in the face and the bar and I just want to
delete that from having happened.
Right?
Like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
and again,
I think that what we're dealing with now is like,
you have to interface with it,
right?
You have to interface with your computer.
You have to interface with your phone to access all this stuff.
My real concern is that that's just a temporary step and that we're going to
just consistently and constantly be interfaced with all of each other.
You know,
Ilan brought something up when he was on the podcast,
um,
called neuro link and he didn't want to fully describe it cause he said he
couldn't,
but he said it's going to be live within,
you know,
a matter of x amount of months.
And he was talking about it increasing the bandwidth between human beings and
information in a radical way that's going to change society.
That is what I'm talking about.
He's talking about an injection you basically do in like your throat and it's a
neural lace and it just,
you know,
threads around your brain,
watts and yeah.
You serious?
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
that's what he's talking about.
Yeah.
So damn alien trying to turn us into robots.
So the question is,
what's the nature of those robots?
Robots are going to exist and they exist,
right?
But should you shoot them into your brain if you're dying of cancer?
Would you,
yeah,
I'd want to see God and see what's up.
So like,
do the nanobots,
you know,
the Kurzweil talks about like,
do we have control as a community over those robots?
What's,
what's the code running those saying are they infallible?
I mean,
what if they crack?
our fucking tricaster crashes every other podcast.
Yeah.
Whether it's open source or free or not,
makes no difference to whether it can fuck up your brain.
Right.
What if somebody puts that shit in and then for whatever reason,
they have a blown fuse and they stomp on the gas and drive right into a tree.
It depends on the level of risk you're willing to take.
I mean,
you see some of those videos I like,
I've cried at those videos where like,
the,
the woman like here for the first time,
you're like,
oh,
yeah,
yeah.
That's something people seeing color for the first time
and putting on certain glasses that allow them to see car.
Yeah.
All this stuff's amazing.
I mean,
that did all that stuff is very cool.
And,
um,
in talking to David Sinclair and he was talking about,
uh,
emerging technologies in with reversing aging and age related diseases.
I mean we're,
we're anting are entering into an incredibly strange time for the,
the influence of technology and innovation on,
on human beings,
on our bodies and our brains.
And we're going to have to decide,
you know,
how,
how far you want to go on this ride next top far rock.
Like when are you getting now?
I lived there,
I lived on the beach.
Then I'm going,
well no,
I don't know.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's like one of those things like what,
where do you get off?
Like when,
what,
where do you go that?
Okay,
that's enough.
You know,
like with you,
you're deleting Facebook,
you lead to delete Instagram and you go just going to be on mines and that's
enough.
And going other places,
I mean these,
there are alternatives that are getting very big yes.
And together like what?
Like signal has tens of millions of users.
I don't know what that is.
I've never heard of it.
That's like the encrypted messaging app that,
do you know it,
it's open source.
What is it?
Snow
is on their advisory board or whatnot.
What is signal?
It's just a messaging APP.
So a message but like a whatsapp or like a Twitter,
whatsapp.
So you have to know the person and then contact them through it.
Yeah,
but we're talking,
we're,
we're considering a,
using the signal protocol for our messaging system cause our messaging system
needs an upgrade.
But all of us together are going to be,
be able to create sort of like a,
a group of apps that are like sort of a more open freedom supporting privacy
alternative and like,
so it's,
we're not gonna solve it by ourselves and
it would be way easier if one of these big companies would just switch gears and
start doing things the right way.
I mean we've spent eight years building this.
If one of the big companies,
Google,
Facebook had just been free and open source,
we would have spent the last seven years building on top of them.
Right.
Because you know,
they already did something cool that they're sharing with everybody.
So it's,
it's actually closed source project stifle innovation because if you think we
had to reinvent the wheel,
we literally,
we went and built an alternative with much of the similar functionality.
Think about how how much further the world would be if everyone was building on
top of more common.
But you are looking at it in terms of your own personal benefit.
You're looking in terms of mine's personal benefit.
I mean you created this thing,
it's not just pure for altruistic reasons.
It's a business,
right?
So if they had established this open source network that was Facebook and he
just came along and built yours,
well that,
yeah,
that would be great for you.
But why would that be great for them?
I mean they,
they're obviously in a business now the problem with the businesses,
this business is the business of distributing information and then we have to
decide,
okay,
at what point in time do we allow these air quotes overlords to dictate what can
and cannot be distributed?
And how did this happen?
Because in the beginning,
I bet it didn't happen.
I bet in the beginning you can just put it on whatever the fuck you wanted and
then they had to deal with that and then they had to figure out after a while,
okay,
maybe we shouldn't have this on like,
hey,
if if we're going to sell advertising,
we really should maximize the amount of clicks.
Okay,
how do we do that?
While we put things in people's feeds,
they want to see,
we put things that people want to debate about and argue about and political
things and all sorts of different things that excite them and get them to be
engaged with the platform that's,
that's their business.
The businesses,
I mean it's no different in a lot of ways than Amazon or then any other business
that wants to grow.
Like how does,
how do they grow while they grow?
By maximizing their profits and by maximizing the amount of eyes that get to
their advertising so they get more clicks and more people get engaged.
That's what their businesses,
you're deciding by saying if they were open source,
look how much further along in the world would be.
They would be further along to,
I don't know if they would agree with that.
I don't think they're there worth fucking cajillions of dollars.
So they figured it out.
Well it just depends on whether or not you think that people have a right to
know what is going on.
It's,
I mean it's like food transparency.
Well yeah,
we were.
Yeah.
We,
so I'll talk about that.
I like,
I will talk about that till the end of the time you were interfacing with this
and it's affecting us.
I agree.
Yeah.
I fully agree with what you're saying.
I'm playing devil's advocate by saying that in their position they have a
business and their business is to make money and they're going to lose because
of what they're doing because it's not even half post losing active users,
are they?
Yeah,
but I thought their business went up after the hearing.
We did it,
but it's not going to last.
I mean,
look,
you say that
it's just the game's over.
It's going to take a long time for us to build it up as you know,
all of these different organizations and companies working together.
But
Linux for instance,
is the operating system that most banks,
it is the most popular operating system.
The world.
It's,
it's,
yeah,
it's open.
So it's in your phone.
It's in everywhere.
It got there because of that,
because everyone used it and incorporate it into their product.
Facebook,
they are all using free and open source software in their stacks.
They're just not sharing their product with everybody else.
So they're benefiting from it but not giving back.
And you know,
I almost feel like I shouldn't even be saying that they should just pivot
because you know,
that's their only chance to survive.
So this is based on your estimations of the future?
Yeah,
it just seems like things are becoming more open and if there's that possible
because you engage with a lot of other super nerds and you guys all have the
similar ideas.
You just have to look at what's happening with bitcoin.
I don't know what's happening with bitcoin.
It's become a bitcoin and ethereum and you know,
lots of other blockchains are,
are,
are growing really fast.
Maybe the,
you know,
the price is separate,
the development energy,
the number of people who are building apps on top of bitcoin and ethereum is
growing massively.
There's,
there's,
it's a whole new infrastructure that's like a common protocol that people can
build on.
So that is growing rapidly.
The price is secondary.
That's not even what bitcoin and ethereum are really about.
It's,
it's,
it's a decentralized database.
So this is just where the Internet,
the Internet is meant to be decentralized.
It sort of started out that way.
And then we moved into this like web to silo system with like just these massive
companies that are controlling everything.
But it's gonna,
it's gonna keep waving.
Okay.
Again,
to play devil's advocate,
the vast amount of users are not using those platforms.
A vast amount of users are using these controlled platforms like Facebook and
Instagram and Twitter.
Like if that's,
if you're,
if you're talking about,
I'm just guessing,
but if you talking about the,
the,
the gross number of human beings that are interacting with each other on social
media,
they're mostly uncontrolled networks.
You're saying this is not gonna last,
but there's no evidence that it isn't going to last.
There's tons of evidence.
What does the evidence,
Wikipedia,
what is happening in card?
I remember that desk you put in your computer,
that was your encyclopedia.
Where is that?
No one uses it.
It's okay.
That's,
that's different.
This is not a social media network.
The social media networks that people are using are almost all controlled,
right?
Yeah.
No it's not.
It's going to take a very,
very long how long?
I would say 10 years.
And what do you think is going to be the catalyst?
Like what's going to cause these people to make this radical shift to open
source?
I think we have to be,
we have responsibility to be competitive functionally.
Like you know one's does.
Yeah.
We just saying we do,
we're getting,
we're moving there fast.
Like we just hired a ton of new developers and it's going to take time.
We're not there yet.
Right.
But once we have functionally competitive products that you wouldn't even know
the difference and there's enough people there,
then it's basically the decision of,
uh,
you know,
am I going to choose the one that respects my privacy and freedom or are the one
that doesn't?
And people,
our kids don't like Facebook,
right?
No.
Everyone is sick of it.
We're just drug addicts.
Hmm.
Um,
is that what it is that just sucked into this thing where you,
you constantly want to check and see who's writing what and,
yeah,
and there's monopolies,
arguably.
Yeah.
Right.
Especially when Facebook owns Instagram.
What if they bought Twitter as well?
They almost did.
I think Google almost an attorney who steps in and buys everything.
Then you look,
oh no,
they probably could.
Right?
Yeah,
they easily could.
They could probably buy everything apple code with cash.
Yeah.
Tim Cook had come in with a big purple pimp suit on,
just slap down a briefcase pitch.
I just wonder and like,
look,
all the,
all these executives,
you know,
Jack seems like a cool person.
He's a very nice guy.
It's not,
I just sent so much inconsistency and you know,
he's talking about Bitcoin,
like it's this important new internet money simultaneous,
which is,
he knows the infrastructure is open,
but then his platforms are the opposite.
Why is he so inconsistent?
It's like there's,
it's just hypocritical to the maximum.
I think it's partly because it's a giant business,
you know?
And I think when you have an obligation to your shareholders and to maximize
profits and when you're trying to maximize profits too,
and there's the,
this universal growth model where every year just has to get a little bit
bigger.
Otherwise you're fucking up as a CEO.
Like you don't have to experience that with mines.
We're one of the cofounders.
How many people are involved?
It's like 15 of us now.
And do you have like a board we sit around when you make critical decisions such
stressful as fuck.
Yeah.
Luckily we've started off from the point where we're saying,
okay,
we're embedding principles into how we're doing things.
So we're not in a position where we would ever change that,
that that's for us to do.
That would just be a total waste of time.
Right.
So we're making it harder for ourselves to make money in the beginning.
We're making it harder for ourselves to grow because we are not gonna compromise
people's privacy in order to do those things.
And so we're just going to build up slowly,
steadily finding it.
Just get there when we get there.
How much time a day is this?
How much of an obligation is this for you?
Same as any job.
I'm,
it's,
it sucks because you know,
my wife Allie would say like,
it's too blurred my life because it's like what is pleasure?
What does,
I mean it's probably happens with you too.
Like when you're on your phone,
like your family doesn't know if you're working or if you're doing something for
fun.
It's like your work is sort of in the digital realm.
Partially a lot of them.
So it's like I just need to put it down like no phones in bed.
These kinds of things like strict lines.
Yeah,
that is,
that is huge.
Strict lines are huge.
Um,
yeah.
Putting your phone in a physical place and pushing it away.
You know,
like that's,
it's huge.
It's just the,
the compulsion to look and check,
like Instagram feeds to see if there's any cool pictures.
Like what the fuck am I doing?
Like why am I compelled to do this?
There's no benefit.
Like occasionally if I'm bored,
like I'm in the dentist's office,
you have 10 minutes.
All right.
What could see what the fuck's going on in the news?
Like maybe occasionally,
but there's so much of your time,
it's dedicated to that.
So much of it,
it's so taxing and it's so involved and so many people are doing.
I mean,
I went to a restaurant the other day and I was looking around and fucking
everyone was sitting at a table looking at their phone.
It's,
we've ever did this stack game.
What's that?
Just like if you're out to dinner with a bunch of people,
just everyone's put their phone in a stack in the middle when you could do it,
then you pay.
Oh,
I'd rather just,
just not,
not,
yeah,
people's people wipe their butts and don't fucking wash their hands.
And touch their phone.
And you know,
your phone is filled with all kinds of dirty shit.
They like done these a swab tests of phones are covered with Ecolab and Pete
were gross.
I'm not [inaudible],
I'm a little Germaphobe.
My fucking hands clean pro.
I'm not,
but I know your phone probably has your butt all over it to just be honest.
That's true.
How long have you don't have to,
but I know what you're saying.
Like it's a good idea.
You know,
um,
uh,
the,
um,
the guys who run Joe beef in Montreal,
it's this amazing restaurant,
uh,
Fred and Dave and they were,
they were talking about it,
but when they go to dinner,
they shut their phone off.
Like I'm going to,
I'm a,
I'm a good guest,
a good table guests.
I shut my phone off.
I don't,
I don't engage it on check it.
It's so,
you know,
it's a,
it's a similar thing to a podcasting in a way in that one of the good benefits
of podcasting is that for three hours or two hours,
whatever the fuck you're doing,
you're going to sit down and you just can engage with a person to see you and I,
me and bill,
we're just talking right.
And that we're not checking our phone,
we're not looking at the television,
we're not looking at the laptop is no distractions.
And that is one of the rare moments in life where you get to talk to someone for
several hours.
And over the last,
you know,
nine years that I've been doing this podcast,
I've,
it's benefited me tremendously just just in having real conversations with
people.
We're just sitting across from somebody for hours.
Just talking to them,
like getting better at understanding how people think,
getting better.
Understanding how,
I think getting way better at communicating in that,
you know,
knowing when to talk and when not to talk and what questions to ask and try to
understand the thought process that another person has and you know,
you walk out of that with some lessons,
like real legit,
tangible lessons.
Those fucking don't happen.
We staring at your phone while you're talking to people,
they like cuts all that off the conversation.
Stay shallow.
You Miss Important points like,
oh,
I'm sorry,
what were we saying?
You do that kind of shit and like then the other person knows you're not
engaged.
It's just,
it's weird.
Yeah,
it's all shades of gray.
I mean it's done incredible things for like democratizing the ability to share
information.
So it's not just these juggernaut media companies are the only places that can
share information.
So it's incredible.
It's crucial.
We need everyone to have the ability to share and so that you can check in
because maybe you're more likely to get the reality of what's going on in the
world from your newsfeed then then the big companies.
But um,
we need management skills.
Yeah.
Personal management skills.
And we,
I think we need to look at them the same way we look at like alcohol consumption
and you know,
even poor food choices.
Like you can have a cheat day and eat a bunch of pizza and some ice cream like
the rock does.
No one's going to get hurt,
right.
But most of the time he's probably take care of your meat vehicle.
I think the same thing can be said of your mind.
Like you can have a day,
like I have a day a week,
well,
I will fucking plop down on the couch and I don't give a fuck.
I just watch bullshit on TV and just relax because I know that I'm red lining it
six days a week,
you know,
and I'm doing three different things at a time.
I have three different jobs and working out and I'm trying
to take care of my family and writing comedy material and then let me see some
document around some wacky fucking cult or,
or whatever the hell I'm going to watch.
And I don't feel guilty when I do that because I know that I've kind of air
quotes earned it,
you know.
But I think that that's,
that's mental management and I think we certainly need,
we need personal management.
It comes to the use of electronic devices.
Yeah.
Personal challenges.
Challenge psychology is really fucking interesting to me.
Like you guys do the Doc Tobar thing.
We're thinking about doing it twice a year now.
I did this one with,
with some of my friends just going to watch shit.
You are you in it to we,
it doesn't get in.
We did one called uh,
the hundred burpee challenge.
How did,
I haven't done burpees and I did them today because I was coming.
I was like,
oh,
I can do burpees tonight,
but uh,
a hundred for time everyday for a hundred days straight and it's,
you are drenched after going for time.
100 burpees.
Oh yeah.
Ridiculous.
So it's hard when it was the best,
most has been have ever been working out and it was like me and five friends.
My friend's mom did it too and it was changed my life.
Really.
It was ridiculous how to change your life.
I felt better than I have ever felt by far.
And I have it.
That was like a year ago and I've,
I've trailed off,
but I think like,
but not just physical challenges like digital ones too.
And like with the ice bucket thing,
that was crazy shit.
I didn't get in them either.
I'm like,
just get watching it happen was just really powerful.
I'm going to throw water on my head during a fucking drought stop.
Yeah.
Everybody stopped.
It's not fixing anything.
How about I just write a check.
I'll give you some money.
Yeah.
Film Yourself.
Writing the check.
Stop.
Yeah.
Throw a glass of water in my face when I'm done with the chuck.
Just stop.
But getting communities to sort of pressure each other into doing things in a
positive way.
In a positive way.
Yeah.
Well,
that was what the sober October thing kind of turned out to be about.
And there's a lot of lessons learned in that too.
You know,
you learn lessons about your reliance on um,
either substances or things.
And one of the things that I learned from the sober October challenge,
the last one was that when you engage in really rigorous physical activity,
six and seven days a week,
you don't give a fuck.
Like you don't give a fuck.
Like all the chatter,
the internal chatter,
it just goes away.
All the negative chatter.
Like it's like taking a pill.
Like I don't give a fuck pill.
It's amazing.
It's really a mate because I think a lot of personal anxiety that people carry
around with them is,
is a physical energy that's not being expressed because I think the body has
certain demands and certain
potential.
And in order to have this certain potential,
like your potential for athletic output,
you have to have this,
you have this energy source,
right?
And this is body energy source when not expressed.
And when you're sitting in a cubicle all day,
day after day after day,
they build this like internal anxious feeling intention and that becomes your
normal,
the,
the normal line,
the normal frequency in which you operate.
You operate under this intense sort of anxious state and you feel like,
well this is life.
God Damn and I'm depressed,
or God dammit,
I'm anxious guy.
I got anxiety,
I've got to see a shrink or got to this.
If you just blow that shit out every day,
every day,
you know,
you burn off 2000 calories and you fucking run for five miles and you do kettle
bells and Chin ups and fucking hit the bag for five rounds,
do that shit goes away.
You don't give a fuck.
And then you get to look at things with real clarity.
So there was a lesson learned in that and then did that lesson was only learned
because we decided to challenge each other and push ourselves.
Do you think it would be too draconian to have like a,
a company,
a hundred burpee a day?
Yes.
Yeah.
You know why man?
I just don't think you should tell people what to do.
They,
their,
their job as the job and then everything else is like a cult,
you know?
It's like,
no,
we're all going to wear white robes.
We don't need anything about white robes.
Okay.
When do you start fucking everybody and taking their money because that always
comes next.
Yeah.
Cause it's in vain.
You can't,
you can't force people.
It's like being convinced,
but it wouldn't be a bad,
well,
the problem is if you were,
you could,
you could have some sort of a companywide challenge.
We're giving bonus site if you do know,
because that's what I'm saying is like you would shame them into doing it or you
would,
uh,
you know,
somehow or another make it seem like they would advance in the company more if
they played along.
Could be,
yeah.
I'm not gonna do it
because it feels so good.
Yes.
Well,
you should encourage it,
but I almost feel like,
um,
yeah,
but you don't want to shame people.
Like there's some brilliant people that don't work out at all.
They're brilliant,
but they just,
whatever,
for whatever reason,
that's their choice.
You know,
it should be your choice to go out like Christopher Hitchens,
it just fucking drink every day and smoke cigarettes and one day he get cancer
and you're like,
well,
you know,
I mean this is like,
he mean he,
the way he described it,
like burning the candle at both ends,
it gave,
uh,
a beautiful,
brilliant light.
Yeah.
He wouldn't have had those ideas if he had done it another way.
It's very possible.
That's true in most of the madness that we see in,
in brilliant artists.
Like it's very,
it's very possible that that madness would not be expressed if they had their
shit together.
There was something that Sam Harris was saying the other day on your show just
about,
about the freewill stuff.
And I think that it,
that connects to this information
theory kind of thing.
So if we're just sort of a conglomerate of these actions and words like flowing
the,
the actions through our body in unique ways.
I mean,
do you accept his theory on freewill?
Um,
well it's not his theory or it's a conventional theory of termism that a lot of
people are embracing and I think there's definitely some merit to it.
However,
you and I both know that you choose whether or not you decide to do something
right.
You choose whether or not you did.
Like someone says,
someone says something to you that's kind of Shitty and you choose whether you
decide to email them back something shitty.
Like you have that initial impulse like a little,
hey man,
fuck you.
You have that initial impulse,
you think on it,
you sleep on it,
but why are you thinking on it and sleeping on it?
Are you doing that because of determinism?
Are you doing that because you're trying to be a better person and are you
trying to be a better person because of all the factors that played out in your
life?
Like environment,
Jean's life experience,
all those things,
right?
It means it's really good.
It's a really good discussion.
So do you own the words that you're saying right now?
It's a good question.
Larry Lessig,
who's on here the other day.
Yeah.
You guys didn't even talk about this,
but he basically is one of the founders of creative Commons and this whole
licensing structure for content.
Like what we're saying right now,
you know this is going to be licensed,
I dunno how you and I'm form right here.
This discussion is going to be licensed you.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean you're,
I think you're licensing it in a certain way.
Okay.
Well you have the ability to license a however you want,
right?
You could say,
hey,
anyone can take this and cut it up and remix it.
Or You could say now it's locked down.
But he helped create this whole licensing array of like six different licenses.
One says you can do absolutely anything you want with this and other says you
can share it,
but you can't make money off it.
There's a handful.
And so the free will stuff is connected to how we're dealing with information.
And like if you,
cause if you,
if you think realistic,
we don't own what we're saying,
we're a part of it,
right?
We're a conduit where unique conduit.
So it,
I don't think it aligns with how the universe works to really be locking down
information.
I think that it makes sense probably in certain short term business,
but you know,
I think we have to open it up to what's really going on.
What do you mean by like locking down information like source code,
like classified files,
like our content,
like music,
like video and now how does it,
how does this connect to determinism and whether or not you have free will
because it's are,
are you the creator of your information?
Mm.
Well
you are certainly,
if you put in the work,
like let's say you decided to write a book.
I mean you put hundreds and hundreds of hours into this book and edit this book
and then you release the book and someone says,
no,
you didn't.
You didn't create that.
You are,
you're a product of determination and I'm going to just steal your book.
That's intellectual theft.
Intellectual theft is real.
It's,
it's certainly real in terms of like creation of content,
right?
If you're a standup comedian and someone takes your countless hours of work and
steals it,
that's intellectual theft for sure.
And then they try to pawn it off as their own through their own selfish needs.
There's a selfish means.
That's why attribution is the key part of the creative Commons licensing
structure.
Always saying if you come up with a joke,
you know,
came from here,
but what if it's a profit?
Like say if you wrote a book and I say,
Hey,
this is a great book written by Bill [inaudible],
give me five bucks for it and putting it up on my site and you to it.
Fuck that.
I mean,
here's the thing.
I don't,
somebody makes all the money off of your book because they have a better
platform to sell your book and they don't give it to you at all.
And you wrote the book,
you spent all the time,
you did all the work.
I would for certain
and content that I create completely give it away.
That sounds like the guy was never written a book.
I've written a book.
Did you?
I mean,
I've,
I've written a lot of content.
Yeah.
But if you've written,
I give away,
I give,
I've not published,
but the book that you sell,
like if you were an author,
but say if you were,
I'm not saying people should be forced to do this.
I can just sometimes I'm just saying that this I think is how creativity happens
and I just,
I just don't,
people deserve to make money on their content.
Right.
And you deserve to own your stuff.
But I don't think that that's actually how the universe works and I don't think
it's acceptable to say,
Oh,
free.
You know,
free will doesn't exist.
I own your content.
But yeah,
that's why I'm struggling to see how they're connected.
Because if you're not the originator,
then you're not the owner.
That's a weird argument because you are the originator.
Stephen King wrote all Steven Qr.
You're the unique conduit.
You are the originator of that specific configuration of information and you
deserve to be able to do everything you're saying with it.
I'm just saying that
Aye.
I Dunno.
It's,
it's complex.
Well,
it is complex.
If you're saying that all human beings,
essentially,
all of your actions have been determined by a lot of factors that are outside of
your control.
Whether it's genetics,
again,
life experience,
education,
all the different factors,
your environment.
Um,
is that what's causing you to,
uh,
put out,
okay.
A fucking brilliant record.
It's part of it,
right?
But maybe you have 50,
maybe you have 50%.
Everything else has 50% or there's weed,
I don't know what the percentages,
but if you're a musician and someone like Spotify comes along and says,
boot didn't even make that dude,
so we're just gonna put it on Spotify and make millions and give you pennies.
That's not what I'm advocating.
I'm,
I'm saying sampling uses the blues died.
Well,
more than that.
More than that.
There's,
yeah.
Yeah.
It was a real plagiarism.
So,
but that doesn't,
that doesn't mean that those aren't great records.
That's true.
It is true.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a led Zeppelin,
this legit gray area.
You know,
I found out this,
uh,
Bill Burke called me up and left us really disturbed message.
He was like really bummed out when he watched.
And Bill's a musician,
he's a drummer.
And when he saw videos of led Zeppelin music played and the band that used to
open for led Zepplin we played it on the podcast.
We were like,
Holy Shit.
Like they just stole stuff.
They just stole giant chunks and rifts and you know,
and,
and I mean they made it better I guess,
but,
but yeah,
but that's a different thing than Stephen King's book.
Why?
Because Stephen King had to spend countless hours in front of his laptop trying
to go over each and every sentence and each and every paragraph and suck you in
all this work.
No,
they stole stuff,
dude.
They sold certain phrases.
But you think he didn't use a single phrase anywhere in any of his books that he
didn't pull from something?
We certainly has.
Yeah.
He certainly has.
Um,
I don't think it's the same though.
I think it's similar led Zepplin what?
They also had to spend countless hours recording that performance to get it to
the level of awesomeness that we heard.
Sure.
That wasn't easy to do.
They just did a bitch ass move and they didn't pay those people.
Yeah.
No matter what you should be attributing,
if you're taking ideas,
put in the footnotes,
why does it hurt?
It doesn't make your art worse because then they'd have to admit they stole the
riff for Stairway to heaven from their opening band.
And then people would go,
what?
And then they would see it.
Then they would look at led Zepplin differently.
But you know,
human beings are fucking severely flawed.
Um,
I don't know if I buy that with this,
this idea that you're saying in terms of like a authors creating content.
I'm not trying to sell something.
No,
I know.
But if they are,
I don't think someone should be able to copy their stuff and sell it.
I don't think they should either.
But what do you think it should be able to do?
You think?
Okay.
You should be able to decide.
So if you,
the content creator,
you should.
Okay.
I agree with that.
Yeah.
It's,
it is.
I mean,
obviously I play devil's advocate a lot,
but that's how you get to the bottom.
And these conversations.
But it is a very complicated issue,
the complicated issue of who you are and why you are
who you are and who you are at this moment versus who you are a decade ago or
two decades ago.
It's,
it's all very weird,
you know,
I mean,
you go back and think about stuff from high school and you're like,
Jesus,
what am I really,
even that person?
Like I think about,
like I've,
I've talked to my sister about stuff that happened when we were in high school.
Hey,
you remember that guy?
And he said to say hi and like,
how's that even me?
Do I ever know that person?
Like is that really me?
Cause I,
if I,
if I see them again I'll be like,
oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
we had a 10th grade science together.
Oh yeah.
Huh.
Crazy.
Like I ran into a guy from my high school like a couple of weeks ago and it was
weird.
It was so weird.
You know,
he remembered some strange story from English class and I was like,
wow,
you remember that?
Like how weird.
And while he was talking me,
I'm like,
is that even really me?
Like,
cause even really talking about me because I don't have any connection to the
stuff that he's saying and I understand that he has,
it's a vague,
distant ghostlike memory in his mind of some,
some slide images that he's pieced together that he recognizes as a past
interaction.
I mean it's fucking strange.
It's super strange to like in,
you know,
50 or 20,
45,
whatever,
you know,
if your body can be replaced one piece at a time,
yeah.
As time goes on,
then your body literally you could survive,
but your body is going to be like almost completely deaf.
Exactly.
It's like,
um,
the,
the boat,
uh,
analogy,
what was,
was it Graham Hancock?
They use that analogy.
Somebody uses the analogy of a certain boats that are like really ancient boats
that are on display in every single piece of them from the original boat has
been replaced because they rotted away and you're like,
okay,
what am I looking at?
What is this really?
Yeah.
And that's kind of us in.
And once that becomes a physical thing,
you know,
I met the guy who got his uh,
arm and his leg a bitten off by a shark.
You're see,
that guy's got carbon fiber,
arms and legs.
John Joseph brought him to the comedy store.
I met him at the UFC when you gave him tickets.
Oh,
shook his hand on,
oh shit.
Weird.
Super,
Super Nice Guy.
But he's got this uh,
uh,
let's like a carbon fiber hand and forearm that moves around like,
like a hand and he shakes your hand and then he walks with no limp.
He's got this carbon fiber audit.
I mean,
I think from the knee down the shark bit his leg off.
It's fascinating.
You know,
you're like,
okay,
you're still a person.
You're still here.
And what there is,
there's a gentleman right there,
Paul de Gelder,
Super Nice Guy,
but is a,
that is a fake arm that he's got from his arm being chopped off by a fucking
shark.
So from a see where it is from his right thigh,
like mid thigh down and his right elbow down,
all that shit chewed off by a shark and he's still jacked.
Look it up.
No excuses.
And that's going to keep becoming more biological,
right?
Well with the real concern is I remember a $6 million man.
Do you remember that television show?
No.
Well you're younger than me.
There was a show called the $6 million man and the $6 million man,
he had been in some sort of a pilot accident and uh,
the gentlemen,
we can rebuild him,
we can make him better than,
he was better,
stronger,
faster.
And they given these bionic parts,
he gave him a bionic arm and they gave him bionic legs and he could run like 60
miles an hour.
You would run like crazy fast.
And he had these artificial arms and aren't artificial leg and they had a bionic
woman,
same shit,
except she was hot and she had artificial legs and I think she could see things
and other people couldn't see like one day.
I mean,
that was cool.
Would you would look at that you're like,
wow,
look,
we could do like he got in a fight with big foot on the TV show.
It's really stupid,
but one day people are going to be given the option.
Do you want to now maybe you want to keep your legs or do you want to get these
legs that allow you to jump over a building?
I'm curious if there's really like superhuman projects that are going on where,
where people actually can have these abilities that,
you know,
we know that with classified information it's just we know what that their stuff
we don't know that are extraordinary projects.
So you know,
this being in the future,
I feel like there's a disconnect between the state of technology on the planet
earth right now with like what the public has access to with what the,
you know,
black projects have access to and that is really not cool because it's not fair
for humanity to not understand what is going on.
I think that's true,
but I also think that most of the state of the art stuff is,
it's peer reviewed,
right?
I mean,
there's so many different people working on these different technologies like
cern,
you know,
they're working on the large hadron collider or anything else.
There's so many different people working on it.
The people that are the forefront of the technology and let's,
they're all gobbled up by the dark government.
They're,
you know,
they're,
they're the people at the head of the line kind of understand where the
technology is that currently for sure for you.
And I,
we don't know what the fuck's going on,
but I think you're right.
I think there's probably some government programs where they scoop up the,
the,
the wisest and the brightest and you know,
like they're got Oppenheimer,
you know,
and got him to develop the Manhattan project.
There's probably some shit going on right now.
What do you think's happening?
What do you know,
Bill?
Tell me.
I want there to be huge freedom of information act reform.
Eh,
they're there.
We know that there are trillions going into the black budget.
So,
uh,
Trevor Paglen wrote a cool book called,
I think it was him called blank spots on the map.
And it's,
it's just talks a lot about the,
the black budget.
And I mean,
we,
so we know it exists.
We know.
I don't know,
but it's,
it's holding us back.
But maybe I'm not saying everything should be shared because what if you have
like a bio weapon?
Right,
right.
You know,
so we need to understand,
I think that we need to push the threshold with what the public has access to.
Like we need to go way deeper.
It's complicated.
Yeah.
It really is.
Right.
You know,
it really is.
Um,
I really appreciate your perspective and I really appreciate your point of view
and I really appreciate your ethics and what you're,
what you're working towards with minds.
And that's one of the reasons why I wanted to talk to.
I think it is important and as much as I fuck around and play devil's advocate,
I do that to try to get to,
to,
you know,
how you're thinking and why and whether or not you've had these arguments in
your own mind.
But,
um,
I think ultimately I've said this before and I'm don't know if it makes sense
because again,
I'm not that smart.
I really wonder if there's,
there's bottlenecks for progress that are going to be that we're going to run
into.
And I think,
um,
ultimately information is one of the big ones and information also in a lot of
ways is money.
You know,
I mean,
when we think of money we're,
we're thinking of ones and Zeros that are being moved around on bank accounts.
It's data.
I mean,
it's attributed to different people and you'd get to do more things because you
have more of these numbers and more of these things.
But what is it really?
It's not gold based anymore.
It's not a physical material,
a material ODG object that you're coveting now it's some weird thing and it's
kind of like information on a database.
And what if we get to a certain point in time,
and I,
I,
I sort of feel like in this weird,
vague,
abstract way we're moving towards this with all,
it's one of the things that I want to really step back and wonder about this
trend towards socialism and,
and social democratic thinking.
I wonder what that is.
And I,
I honestly think that we're moving towards this idea that,
hey,
you know,
we've got a lot of fucking problems that could be cured if you move some of that
money around and,
but,
but should you be able to move some of that money around?
And when,
what happens if that money becomes something different than what if people start
developing social currency instead of financial currency would have your ability
to do things was based on how much you actually put in.
I mean,
we're assuming,
right?
We assume that the way we do things now where if you want to buy a car,
you have to have $35,000 that's how much a Mustang costs and you've got to bring
it to the bank and this and that.
And you can prove alone.
But what if we get to a time in the future where it's not these pieces of paper
that gives you material objects but rather your own actions and deeds provide
you with social currency that allows you to on vacations or allows you to eat at
restaurants.
It allows you to do things and there's this running tally that's not outside of
the realm of possibility.
No,
I think it really
award systems within everything that we're using are gonna are gonna rise up.
I mean that,
that's it's what we're already kind of doing.
I mean we,
we reward tokens for,
for activity.
We're going to see that rise up in more things
doing.
But what I'm saying is if we're doing it in,
if it's a social currency and that your own personal behavior allows you to
access more freedoms or,
or more goods or more things,
it would encourage positive behavior and community based behavior because that
would be the only way to advance.
I mean,
obviously this is a long time down the line,
but when the first cave man,
you know,
traded the first fucking shiny rock for the first spearhead,
whatever it was that they did that started this whole inevitable trend towards
money.
This is not something that has to be this way forever.
You know?
And I wonder when we're looking at the distribution of information,
which is arguably not arguably,
it's never,
never been like what we have today.
There's never been a time in human history where everyone had so much access to
information that you used to have to pay for.
He used to have to go to schools.
You have to use to have to earn your way to the position where you could open
the very books that had all this information in it night,
get it off your phone.
It's instant.
And I,
this is a whole different way of interfacing with information and I think this
is going to affect higher learning institutes.
I think it's going to affect a lot of different things.
But I wonder if this all can be applied ultimately some day,
maybe not.
In our generation,
but someday to money that people start using social currency and that social
currency is going to be almost like we have some sort of a,
a database of social currency in this country,
distributed database.
As long as the government can be running on open systems.
I think the,
the reason we struggle with,
you know,
trusting the government to distribute wealth is because it's,
it's so inefficient.
We want to be deciding where it goes.
Well,
they're also corrupt as fuck.
I mean there's no,
no doubt about that.
I mean,
at the end of the day,
that's a giant problem period.
If the people that are deciding what we can and can't do with information or
also corrupt,
which it means there's laws that allow them to be corrupt but doesn't mean that
they're not corrupt.
I feel like every politician,
the only politicians that I would support at this point,
I want to be pulling us in a direction like that is making their own position
irrelevant.
Basically building open,
secure voting systems that allow the planet or the country to decide and vote on
what we're doing.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I just think that we need more accurate representation of the consciousness of
the communities and it just shouldn't just be these singular people deciding for
everybody when we should have,
we have the tech right.
And by the time they get in there,
they're so compromised by the special interest groups that are helping them out
and all the different people that are contributing to their campaign funds.
MMM.
Do you see anybody like that on the horizon?
I think that there are not specifically right now,
I don't,
I don't see anyone talking about open systems and secure voting and completely
changing the way that we're making decisions.
But I think that's probably just because they don't know about it.
I think there will be a lot of politicians who,
who would be okay with that or want us to move in that direction.
But I think we need more technologists,
scientists in these positions building the things that we're using.
Yeah.
And with an ethic of freedom.
All right,
dude,
that's great conversation,
man.
I really appreciate it.
Okay.
Um,
tell people how they can get on mines,
how they can check it out.
And uh,
you have,
uh,
do you guys have an app as well as,
we have an APP.
You go to [inaudible] dot com slash mobile to get the APP.
We're now on Google play.
We are still in the apple store.
Google play won't let you in?
No.
How come?
Uh,
had issues.
They're scanning the nipple,
but uh,
you find me?
[inaudible] dot com slash shop man,
hopefully we'll get you on there.
Well,
I'm on,
I just,
yeah,
I haven't posted anything.
All right.
You sent me my tower.
Ogun yeah.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Thanks buddy.
Thank you.
I asked her coming on,
man.
It was really fun.
I think we've got a lot out of it.
Thanks.
Great.